One, two.
Also dieses neue, tolle digitale Studio.
Was denn?
Jetzt hast du einfach mal den Mikro aufgedreht.
Ja, sieh doch einfach den Kopfhörer aus, wenn du unter dem Kopfhörer nix hörst.
Ja toll, aber Radio ist ja ohnehin nicht interaktiv.
Ne eben, das ist unidirektional vor allen Dingen. Hier ist das Chaosradio 70, einen wunderschönen guten Abend liebe Höhrenden. Im Studio der Andreas, der Frank und der Andy.
Ich heiße Andy.
Ach echt nicht?
Also Andy, der ICAN-Direktor. Chaosradio 70 ist, worum geht's denn heute? Mich hat ja wieder mal keiner aufgeklärt.
Es geht heute um so zwei grobe Dinge, einmal den Zustand des Internet im Allgemeinen und im Speziellen noch so die Zustände bei ICAN und bei nordrhein-westfälischer Internetzen sogar.
Nordrhein-westfälische Internetzen? Ach das ist, wo man jetzt nicht mehr auf Sexseiten darf, oder? Nee, Nazis hatten wir, als sie diese rausschmeißen wollten.
Genau, also erst wollten sie sowieso alle Perverslinge rausschmeißen, wie Rotten dort kommen und ähnliche. Und nachdem sie dann eingesehen haben, dass es schwierig ist, irgendwie alle Perverslinge aus dem Internet rausschmeißen, haben sie sich zumindest jetzt auf die Nazis konzentriert.
Lass mich raten, ccc.de kann man aus Nordrhein-Westfalen auch nicht mehr ansurfen?
Nein, so schlimm ist es nicht. Also es ist im Grunde genommen so, dass der Regierungspräsident der Bezugsregierung Düsseldorf, der probiert aus, inwieweit er eine Regelung des Mediendienstesstaatsvertrags zu interpretieren kann, dass er eindeutig illegale Inhalte, das heißt, sie haben Abstand genommen von jugendgefährdenden Inhalten, das war der erste Anspruch, und dann haben sie sich jetzt darauf beschränkt, nur illegale Inhalte, das heißt, solche, gegen die es in Deutschland Gesetze gibt, halt Aufruf zu diesem und jenen. Das sind halt recht extremistische, es gibt ja recht radikale und recht extremistische Seiten, und in diesem Fall geht es also um Inhalte, die aus dem Ausland verbreitet werden, wenn auch in deutscher Sprache und die halt aus Rechtsräumen, in diesem Fall hauptsächlich aus den USA kommen, wo es eben kein Gesetz dort dagegen gibt. Das ist aber sicherlich erstmal nur der Anfang, weil das Ganze ist ja der Versuch, die Internet-Service-Provider in Nordrhein-Westfalen dazu zu kriegen, eben mal mit solchen Maßnahmen anzufangen, und wenn das dann flutscht, dann werden auch alle anderen ausgeblendet.
Ihr wart ja auch auf der CeBIT, nicht? Dieser Tage? Echt nicht, ich war keiner auf der CeBIT. Ich hätte mir jetzt so gerne mal erzählen müssen, wie es so war.
Ich war auch nicht auf der CeBIT. Das war das erste Mal seit zwölf Jahren nicht auf der CeBIT.
Ich auch, genau.
Das war total entspannend.
Ich war auch nicht auf der CeBIT, das heißt, wir werden heute den ganzen Abend nicht über die CeBIT reden.
Genau, super.
Ich war ja in Ghana auf der ICON-Konferenz und das war auch viel entspannender als die CeBIT.
Also was ich da so gelesen hab von der Konferenz, war, dass auch alles anhand des Anwaltenspars. Weil da kein Telefon geht und der Zug nicht kommt.
Nee doch, Telefon geht, da ist die richtig GSM, das Netz heißt Spacephone. Das heißt, du hast die ganze Zeit, guckst auf dein Telefon, da steht Spacephone.
Du brauchst dir kein Logo runterladen, ne?
Sehr entspannte Menschen auch. Genau. Chaosradio 70. Wir wollen ein bisschen über den Zustand des Internets reden.
Ist es kaputt?
Nein, es ist nicht kaputt, aber der Kulturraum, der leidet im Moment. Und das liegt unter anderem daran, dass das Internet ja nicht nur ein Haufen von Computern ist, sondern das sind auch Kommunikationsdienste. Und weil Menschen sich so schlechten Nummern merken können, das ist sozusagen das Grundübel, was dem allen zugrunde liegt. Wurde das Domain Name System erfunden. Das Domain Name System ist zum Beispiel das, mit dem der Herr Bisseau in Düsseldorf jetzt versucht, den Zugang zu bestimmten Seiten zu sperren. Das heißt, Zensur anzuführen. Es ist aber auch dasselbe System. Also eben das System, was sozusagen die Namen der Computer auf ihrer IP-Nummer mappt, wo auch dieses ganze Icon-Gemetzel im Moment drum geht. Bei Icon ist ja gerade so ein bisschen, ja, wie soll ich sagen, verschiedene Verwirrungen sind eingekehrt, nachdem jetzt die neuen Top-Level-Domains alle aktiv sind. Also Punkt Info, Museum bis Ero und diesen ganzen Schnickschnack gibt es jetzt. Und die Vergaberechtlinien dafür sind auch so halb geklärt. Deswegen widmet sich Icon mal wieder seinen eigenen Problemen zu. Wenn man keine hat, macht man sich solche. Und was da also gerade passiert ist, dass eigentlich sollten ja jetzt diese Benutzer gewählten Direkturen, vor denen ich einer bin, wir sind ja alle nur bis November 2002, also dieses Jahr gewählt und eigentlich sollten jetzt neue Wahlen gerade verabschiedet werden, aber diese Laden sind sie aber nicht, weil unser Geschäftsführer hat gerade keinen Bock mehr, der sagt, dieser ganze Laden funktioniert ja nicht und man müsste doch die Regierung dran beteiligen.
Welche?
Na also alle Regierungen, das liegt an vollen Problematik. Man muss sich ganz kurz vorstellen, iKON ist also zusammengesetzt aus dem landesspezifischen namensfreuen Betreiber, den sogenannten CCTL, die es also für Deutschland zum Beispiel DE ist ja das DENIC und das gibt es halt in jedem Land. Dann gibt es diese generischen Com org.net, Info Museum und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gibt es noch die Registrars, das heißt die die Domainnamen verkaufen und diese ganzen Leute also in diesem Domain Name Bereich. Und die CCTL, die ist also die landesspezifischen namensfreuen Betreiber, die zahlen halt an iKON keine Gebühren und gar nichts, weil sie sagen, warum denn? Uns hat es vor euch gegeben, uns wird es nach euch geben, warum sollen wir für etwas bezahlen, was uns nicht mal eine Dienstleistung bringt? iKON sagt dann zwar, ja, aber wir betreiben die Rootname-Server, allerdings stimmt das halt nicht, weil die Rootname-Server, da gibt es halt 13 Stück, wer sich dafür interessiert, www.dnso.org, da findet ihr die Liste der aufgestellten Fahnen, da gibt es wunderschöne Mappen und Standortbeschreibungen und so weiter und so fort. Die werden halt, also 13 sind es insgesamt, 10 davon in den USA, davon etwa 7 auf US-Militärgelände, die restlichen stehen in irgendwelchen Universitäten rum. Jedenfalls der Betreiber ist durchgehend nicht iCons, sondern es sind teilweise Militärs. Ja guck doch, bitteschön, du gehst hier auf... Oh, die haben eine neue Seite, die ich gerade hatte. Aber auf FAQ, da müsste es das geben. Hier, Map auf 13 Hunden im Server.
Liebe Hörfunkfreunde, wir melden uns gleich wieder, wenn die Herrschaft fertig ist.
Also die Hälfte davon steht offenbar in Virginia.
Virginia, Arlington, das ist genau da, wo die NSA sitzt.
Ist da nicht auch Area 51?
Ja genau, das ist in Arizona.
Wissen wir, wo für Area 51 gut ist?
Nee, Area 51 ist auf der anderen Seite, das ist in Arizona.
Na, wer weiß, was da auch geht.
Jedenfalls, der Trick ist eben, diese ganzen Runden im Server, das heißt, das Internet von seiner Funktion her, den Internet-Servers, wobei dann dieses Planeten mitzuteilen, wo denn jetzt welcher Namensraum zu finden ist, wo eben welche Top-Level, ob jetzt landesspezifische oder generisch zu finden ist. Das ist eben nicht wirklich in der Hand von ICAN in dem Sinne, sondern diese ganzen Computer werden von Universitäten, Militärs und sonstigen Leuten betrieben. ICAN bezahlt die nicht mal. Das will ICAN natürlich ändern. ICAN will Macht und mehr Macht. Das Problem daran ist, ICAN agiert ja sowieso nur mit Vorbehalt der US-Regierung. Das heißt, jede Entscheidung muss vom Wirtschaftsministerium genehmigt werden und so fort. Und weil die amerikanische Regierung aus anderen Gründen im Moment so ein bisschen unentspannt ist, kam von daher wohl die Initiative, dass man jetzt sagt, naja, eigentlich benutzergewählte Direkturen und diesen ganzen Demokratie-Schnick-Schnack, das ist doch irgendwie auch nicht mehr zeitgemäß, wo man gerade Militärdiktatur aufbaut. Also ich weiß es nicht. Es ist jetzt eine Interpretation zu begeben.
Gibt es denn da von den anderen, von den internationalen ICAN-Direkturen, also den nicht-amerikanischen, nicht irgendwie mal eine Initiative zu sagen, lass uns die Sache doch mal ein bisschen auf internationalere Beine stellen.
Ja, das ist genau der Trick, was passiert ist. Wir haben das ja getan. Wir haben ganz offiziell ICAN sozusagen den Auftrag gegeben, doch die Bedingungen, die die amerikanische Regierung mal ICAN gegeben hat. Also ICAN agiert unter einem Mammarunning of Understanding mit der amerikanischen Regierung. Und wenn die Bedingungen in diesem MOU erfüllt sind, dann darf ICAN ohne die amerikanische Regierung endlich zum Beispiel die Rootzone-Datei administrieren.
Ja, aber möchte das die amerikanische Regierung, dass ICAN das macht? Was jetzt mal davon abgesehen ist, die amerikanische Regierung wahrscheinlich nicht mehr weiß, worüber da gesprochen wird.
Also sagen wir es mal so, ob sie das möchte oder nicht möchte, das ist jetzt im Bereich, das kann ich dir jetzt zwar beantworten, aber streng genommen hat die amerikanische Regierung sich dazu noch nie geäußert. Es liegt natürlich auf der Hand, dass angesichts des Zustands, in dem sich die amerikanische Regierung befindet, ob das mit geistiger Gesundheit zu tun hat oder nicht, dass das irgendwie nicht der Fall ist. Aber offiziell ist das sozusagen eine offene Frage. Und insofern könnte ICANN theoretisch die Bedingungen erfüllen, die in diesem Papier drinstehen. Und dann könnten sie endlich ohne die amerikanische Regierung diesen Quatsch machen. Deswegen haben wir sozusagen mal den Beschluss gefasst, wir drängen jetzt ein bisschen, wir haben gesagt, wir möchten, dass diese Bedingungen erfüllt werden. Und dann werden wir mal sehen, was passiert. Und mit sozusagen ausgerechnet diesem Auftrag hat jetzt der Geschäftsführer gesagt, ja, also mit der bisherigen ICANN Struktur lassen sich diese Bedingungen ja überhaupt nicht erfüllen. Und zum Beispiel, um die landesspezifischen Betreiber alleine mal dazu zu bringen, Verträge mit uns abzuschließen, damit das alles schön stabil ist, müssen wir ja die Regierung mit ins Boot nehmen, damit wir nämlich Druck auf die ausüben können, damit die endlich Verträge mit uns unterzeichnen und uns das Geld erzahlen. Das ist also nicht gerade die Methode, die man als konsensual und im freundschaftlichen Verhältnis irgendwie bezeichnet, sondern das ist eher so, ich arrangiere mich halt mit deinem Chef, der macht dir dann Ärger und dann musst du mir Geld geben und mit mir einen Vertrag unterzeichnen. Also das ist sozusagen die Vorgehensweise. Und die will er jetzt tatsächlich durchziehen, wobei er dazu eben vom Vorstand noch gar keinen Auftrag hat, sondern im Grunde genommen hat er da nur eine Meinungsäußerung getan, aber das Ganze hat natürlich eine gewisse Eigendynamik und insofern stellt sich, ich will das jetzt nicht stundenlang ausführen, aber auch hier so ein bisschen die Frage, ob das DNS, wenn die Regierungen nämlich direkt an EICL beteiligt sein, dann könnten die natürlich auf die Idee kommen. Man hat ja gesehen, was passiert ist, nachdem die Markenrechtsanwälte EICL übernommen haben. Jetzt gibt es sowas wie Markenrechtswirkungen. Na die Markenrechtsanwälte haben halt EICL insofern übernommen, als dass sie beispielsweise Regelungen haben. Bei dieser Punkt-Info-Domain war das ja auch berüchtigt. Die wurde eingeführt. Die ersten 100 Tage durften sowieso nur Markenrechtsinhaber sich einen Domainnamen holen. Dann haben viele Leute sich einen Domainnamen geholt, die einfach so getan haben, als haben sie einen und die sind jetzt wieder rausgeflogen. Aber auch ansonsten gibt es halt so Streitschlichtungsregelungen, die sogenannte UDRP. Das heißt, wenn du einen Domainnamen hast und dann kommt jemand, der hat diesen Domainnamen als Warnzeichen, egal in welchem Land auf diesem Planeten, dann bist du denen bloß. Dann gibt es irgendwie so eine Streitschlichtungsprozedur, die kannst du dann noch initiieren. Aber die meist gewählte Streitschlichtungsinstanz, die angeblich ganz neutral agiert, ist die WIPO, also die World Intellectual Property Organization, eben der Sozialen Weltverband der Markenrechts- und Geistigen Eigentumsschützer. Und dass die nicht so schrecklich unparteiisch sind, das liegt wohl auf der Hand. Und wenn man sozusagen diese Erfahrung, die man da jetzt hat, also diese Markenrechtsgeschichte, die es relativ berüchtigt und die es auch die im Grunde genommen Angelegenheit, die zur meisten Kritik aneignen führt, oder eine der Angelegenheiten, wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, dass die Regierungen damit reinkommen und dann vielleicht noch die amerikanische Regierung ganz direkt sagt, ja wissen wir, diese und jene inhaltlichen Anbieter, der Herr Hussein im Irak und so weiter und fort, die hätten halt theoretisch die Macht, ganze Länder einfach auszutragen. Also denen die Registris auszutragen, oder vielleicht noch perfider die Registris zu kopieren und dann unvollständig zu kopieren. Also einfach nur diejenigen Inhalte, die ihnen gefallen rauszulassen. Genauso kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, die chinesische Regierung hat auch nicht unbedingt das Interesse an größtmögliche Informationsfreiheit, zumindest nicht für ihre eigenen Bürger. Und da gibt es ja so einige. Und das ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, wenn ICANN tatsächlich diesen Weg gehen sollte jetzt. Ich bin leider nicht wirklich in der Lage, das in meiner Minderheitenposition zu verhindern. Ich kann das höchstens als nahe mitverfolgen und dann auch vermelden. Dann stellt sich halt die Frage, ob man überhaupt noch Internet will, was auf dem Domain-Name-System von ICANN basiert. Oder ob man sich nicht einfach wieder darauf konzentriert, dass man eigentlich ja ein Internet hat. Das funktioniert ja zum Glück auf der Ebene von IP-Nummern. Also wir brauchen das Domain-Name-System eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Wir könnten alternative DNS aufsetzen oder uns einfach Web-Server mit schickmerkbaren IP-Nummern zunehmen.
Wobei die Anzahl der schickmerkbaren IP-Nummern doch relativ begrenzt ist.
Also ich meine, der Problempunkt, der Problempunkt ist natürlich, dass irgendwie also ohne DNS-System geht es nicht so richtig. Oder zumindest nicht ohne eine brauchbare Alternative. Insofern wird dann eher irgendwie die Frage...
Du hast eine Domain Name Melling-Liste, das ist also dein eigenes DNS. Das ist ein relativ großes Pfeil, aber...
Ja, so hat das ja früher funktioniert. Da wurde eine Datei namens Posts per FTP verteilt. So einmal am Tag.
Dann machen wir das eben wieder. Dann muss der Web.de Internetführerschein eben um genau diese Funktion ergänzt werden, damit Oma das auch kapiert.
Das ist schon so weit, die Leute machen Internetführerschein nach Hause?
Das ist total klasse. Mein Vater, der ist Rentner. Nein, nein. Aber mein Vater ist ja richtig Rentner. Und er meinte, ich habe mir jetzt einen Computer, ich will auch mal Internets machen. Dann habe ich da bei Web.de gesehen, da gibt es einen Internetführerschein, da kannst du kostenlos eine CD bestellen. Die habe ich ihm auf den Tisch geschmissen. Und der hat es innerhalb eines Tages begriffen. Und der schickt Mails in TXT und nicht in HTML jetzt.
Also ich sehe hier gerade irgendwie F-Root-Servers, nicht Formalie, NS-Nic-DDN-MIL, E-Root-Servers, nicht Formalie, AOSAL, ARMY-MIL. Dann gibt es hier noch so andere Formalie, NS-NASA, GOF und so.
Ja, ja, die haben jetzt teilweise etwas neutralere Namen bekommen, weil das etwas zu offensichtlich wurde.
Chaosradio 70 hier, wir läuten mal eben die nächste Runde ein. Nächste Runde sag ich da.
Sag mal, was ich mich manchmal frage, wozu braucht man dieses Icon eigentlich?
Das wollte ich auch gerade fragen.
Naja, also ich meine, es zahlt mir ja mal im Reisekosten zu interessanten Plätzen dieser Welt und ich kann mich da mit einem Haufen von Leuten herum ärgern. Also damals war es so. Icon ist ja eigentlich die Nachfolge von der IANA und IANA ist im Grunde genommen nichts weiter als der Name für das, was John Postel gemacht hat. John Postel war halt derjenige, der eine Datei gepflegt hat, die hieß ursprünglich mal host.txt und daraus ist dann die Rootzone-Datei irgendwann geworden. Und das Ganze hat halt in den Urschleim so angefangen, dass beispielsweise in Deutschland irgendjemand auf die Idee gekommen ist, es gibt doch da diesen ISO 3166-2-Code für Deutschland, der heißt.de und da könnte man doch einen Namensraum aufsetzen unter eben.de. Und dann hat derjenige irgendwie den Postel angerufen, hat gesagt, wir sitzen hier in einem Land namens Deutschland, Europa und würden gern da einen Datemang aufsetzen für Deutschland. Und dann hat der Postel gesagt, keine Ahnung, wo Deutschland ist, Europa, nie gehört. Aber stimmt, in dieser ISO 3166-Tabelle steht das hin. Also sagt mir mal die IP-Nummer eures Rechners. Und dann hat er das eingetragen und das war der komplette Verwaltungsakt. So, irgendjemand musste das halt machen. Irgendjemand musste halt diese Datei fliegen und das hat er halt gemacht. Und so sind, also so oder so ähnlich, sind halt viele Namensräume entstanden, ohne dass die nationalen Regierungen überhaupt das mitgekriegt haben. Weil die hatten ja immer anderes zu tun. Die mussten ja lauter Gesetze machen und was nicht alles. Und haben das mit dem Internet sozusagen eine Zeit lang, könnte man fast sagen, verschlafen. Es gab zwar ein, zwei Länder, die Franzosen beispielsweise, da haben wir staatliche Organisationen gleichgemacht. Aber na gut. Und ICAN gründet sich sozusagen als Institutionen aus der Geschichte heraus ab, dass halt eine Menge Leute, als das Internet dann wichtig wurde für Wirtschaft, für Wissenschaft, für Regierung und so fort, dann haben die irgendwann herausgefunden, es gibt da diesen einen Typ, diesen John Postle. Und das ist halt wirklich, es gibt da auch Bilder von ihm. Ich glaube, hier an der Org sieht man das noch, da ist halt so ein Typ mit Rauschebart und die meiste Zeit des Jahres hat halt nicht mal Schuhe getragen und ist da irgendwie Badelatschen durchgegangen. Und die haben halt dieses... Mehr oder weniger. Die haben halt diesen Typen gesehen und haben gesagt, Moment mal, der reagiert weltweit das Internet. Das kann irgendwie nicht sein. Und dann ist die Forderung aufgekommen, eine United Nations Treaty Organisation aufzubauen. Also gut, das ist jetzt leicht vereinfacht, diese Version. Aber als dann die Forderung aufkam, eine United Nations Treaty Organisation auszubilden, haben die Amerikaner sich natürlich überlegt, Moment mal, bei den Vereinten Nationen, da haben wir ja nicht so die Mehrheit wie überall anders in diesen sogenannten internationalen Organisationen. Und das ist doch irgendwie eine schlechte Idee. Und wir könnten ja mit der Begründung, dass das auch viel zu viel Bürokratie wäre, einen alternativen Vorschlag machen. Dann hat das DOC, also das Wirtschaftsministerium, so ein White Paper, dann ein Green Paper. Und schließlich ist dann ICANN als kalifornische Firma sozusagen von der US-Regierung gegründet worden. Übrigens ursprünglich noch mit Zustimmung von John Postel, der halt leider auch, naja, der hat seine Kohle halt auch vom DOD, vom Wirtschafts-Eck, vom Verteidigungsministerium gekriegt, auch wenn er an der Universität von Kalifornien saß. Und als dann ICANN gegründet war und mehr oder weniger gerade in seinen Betrieb eingehen sollte, da hat John Postel es dann bevorzugt, einen Herzinfarkt zu bekommen und kurzfristig zu versterben. Für Verschwörungstheoretiker natürlich, wie kann man da noch weitere Ausführungen jetzt andeuten. Jedenfalls ist dann ICANN sozusagen gekommen und weil die anderen Regierungen aber diese United Nations-Nummer schon angefangen hatten, hat die amerikanische Regierung dann gesagt, naja, wir machen das natürlich nicht ganz allein, sondern ihr dürft alle mitspielen, ihr dürft alle mitregieren und dann hat man das GAC erfunden, das Governmental Advisory Committee, das also eine Art Beratungsgremium gibt, das macht man ja immer. In so internationalen Organisationen habe ich mittlerweile gelernt, man gibt den Leuten halt den Eindruck, sie sind irgendwie beteiligt. Das sind dann so interessante Gesprächsrunden, deren Ergebnisse weitgehendst ignoriert werden. So weit, so lustig. ICAN gründet sich sozusagen aus dem Anspruch heraus, dass bestimmte Dinge ja unique im Sinne von einheitlich geregelt werden muss, dass es eben keine zwei Namensräume geben darf mit demselben Namen und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist halt dieser... Stuart Lin hat auch selber ein Papier geschrieben, wo er das jetzt nochmal päpstlicher als der Paar es erklärt hat, nämlich du darfst keine anderen Götter haben neben dir oder auch es gibt nur einen Namensraum im Internet und den regelt eben ICAN. Und das ist natürlich eine völlige Unverschämtheit, angesichts der Tatsache, dass eine Menge von Interessen zum Beispiel dafür sorgen, dass es eben nicht 100 oder ein paar 100 oder vielleicht sogar 1000 generische Namensräume gibt, zumindest nicht im ICAN DNS, sondern eben gerade mal jetzt 7 plus, die bestehenden irgendwie 5 oder so etwas. Und es gibt ja Alternative. Paul Garan zum Beispiel www.namespace.org glaube ich, der macht sowas wie Punkt Sachs, also was weiß ich Coca Cola Punkt Sachs oder Radio Fritz Punkt Sachs, kennt davon, andere, was auch immer, hat ein Domain für die Beschimpfung von Unternehmen, für ihre gesellschaftlichen Folgen, ihres Handels und so weiter und so fort. Das wäre mit ICAN insofern unvereinbar, als das ICAN in dem Gremium, was die Domainangelegenheiten regelt, die sogenannte IPC eingeführt hat, die Intellectual Property Constituency. Das heißt, man hat sowieso den Bereich verlassen, wo es nur noch technisch und administrative Richtgänge gibt, was eigentlich der ICAN Auftrag ist, sondern man hat da geistige Eigentumsleute und Markenrechtler irgendwann mal reingelassen und die ist man nicht mehr los geworden in Montevideo, wo ich letztes Jahr im September war, waren von den 600 Teilnehmern ungefähr 350 Markenrechtsanwälte. Man kann sich also vorstellen, das war eine entspannte Veranstaltung. Das ist lauter, netter, also der...
Also wer war das?
Nee, L'Oreal war es nicht, sondern dieser Dinge. Woody Allen hat das mal gesagt. Von wegen, es gibt Schlimmeres als den Tod ein Abend mit einem Juristen. Na gut, also das ist jedenfalls ICAN. Und wer sozusagen sein DNS reparieren will, wie ich gerade gelesen habe, ist das der neue Sprachgebrauch. Zum Beispiel ist der Open-Route-Server-Configuration www.openrsc.org Der kann halt seinen eigenen DNS-Bereich erweitern, um eben die paar hundert neue Domains, die es längst gibt. Es gibt ja Unternehmen wie new.net, die aus der Frustration um diesen protektionistischen, protektionistische Gehabe von ICAN eben einfach eigene Domains aufgesetzt haben. Es gibt namespace.org und es gibt wie gesagt openrc.org, die so ein bisschen versuchen, als Mittler zwischen denjenigen, die neue Namensräume betreiben, da wiederum eben eine Einheitlichkeit einzuführen. Weil das ist natürlich problematisch, wenn es beispielsweise zwei Punkt-Sachs-Räume gäbe mit einheitlichen, also mit ein und denselben wiederum Second-Level-Domains, weil dann E-Mails halt nicht mehr eindeutig zugeleitet werden können und das wäre irgendwie ein bisschen doof.
Ja, es gibt nur kein Tool, das es mir ermöglicht beide... Echt?
Du meinst jetzt beide zu unterscheiden, wenn es zwei neun sind?
Dass ich sowohl.sax verstehe als auch.org.
Doch, doch, doch. Du kannst ja in den meisten Clients auch mehrere DNS-Server angeben.
Ach so, ja, stimmt.
Und kannst einfach sagen, also wie gesagt, da gibt es ja noch Anleitungen, also insbesondere den new.net, die sind wirklich so drauf, dass sie clicky-bunti-Tools mitliefern, die, Entschuldigung, jetzt diesem Begriff, chimpanzenkompatibel sozusagen die Benutzung mehrerer DNS und darunter eben auch der Alternativen zulassen.
Wenn du fallst rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Das Wetter heute Nacht um minus zwei, ja minus zwei Grad. Und jetzt nochmal für die Landwirtschaft zum Mitschreiben, minus zwei Grad. Morgen dann freundlich und trocken, genauso wie wir hier bei Temperaturen um die elf Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Werner.
Bei einem pasendistinendischen Selbstmordanschlag auf einem Hotel in der israelischen Stadt Netanya sind mindestens 15 Menschen getötet worden. 80 Personen wurden zum Teil lebensgefährlich verletzt. Eine Klarheit den Gipfel der arabischen Liga in Beirut überschattet. Die palästinensische und die saudiarabische Delegation verließen den Sitzungssaal. Damit reagierten sie auf die Nichtübertragung der Rede von Palästinenser Präsident Arafat aus Ramallah. Zwei Tage nach der Erdbeben Katastrophe in Afghanistan ist die Region heute von starken Nachbeben erschüttert worden. Angaben aus Kabul zufolge gab es dabei erneut Tote und Verletzte. Indessen ist die internationale Hilfe angelaufen. Die Personalräte sowie der Vorstand der angeschlagenen Berliner Bankgesellschaft haben sich auf eine vorläufige Sanierungsvereinbarung geeinigt. Danach sollen die Personalkosten um rund 300 Millionen Euro gesenkt werden. Innerhalb der kommenden drei Jahre müssen rund 4.000 Mitarbeiter die Bank verlassen. Der ADAC rechnet für morgen mit dem Beginn der großen Osterreisewelle. Wie im gesamten Bundesgebiet kann es auch am grünen Donnerstag auf den Brandenburger Straßen zu Staus kommen. Und jetzt zum Sport im Fußball-Länderspiel zwischen Deutschland und den USA. In Rostock gewann Deutschland mit 4 zu 2.
Fritz hat eine neue Sendung. Der Fritz-Kommunikator. Die Deutschstunde im Radio mit Knorkator. Jeden Sonntag zwischen 18 und 19 Uhr.
Wir wollen, es geht uns vor allen Dingen darum...
Was jetzt?
Wir wollen?
Das geht uns...
Lass mir doch mal, lass ausreden mich doch mal. Es geht darum, dass es uns so ein Halse raushängt, dass die Menschen, die jungen, nicht überhaupt nicht wissen... Also wenn die reden, gar nicht wissen, die können überhaupt keine Sätze sagen und das wollen wir verändern.
Der Fritz-Kommunikator. Die Deutschstunde im Radio mit Knorkator. Jeden Sonntag zwischen 18 und 19 Uhr und im Radio...
Chaosradio 70 hier, wir sprachen immer noch über alternative Roots.
Aber dazu machen wir mal eine eigene Sendung. Das war eigentlich nicht das Thema der Sendung, sondern es ging ja um das sozusagen Kontrolle im Internet, um den Zustand des Kulturraums, Internet und insbesondere das, was in Nordrhein-Westfalen gerade passiert. Wir haben ja jetzt auch eine Demonstration gerade in der Organisation. Der CCC Köln ist gerade dabei für den 6.
April.
Es ist ein Samstag in Düsseldorf. Eine Demonstration eben gegen diese Einführung von Zensur durch Herrn Büsow da zu machen. www.netzzensur.de zum Beispiel. Da gibt es den entsprechenden Aufruf mit allen Schikanen.
Ja, naja, also dieses Zensurthema ist ja doch irgendwie... Also eigentlich haben wir uns ein bisschen überrascht gehabt. Eigentlich nicht damit gerechnet, dass dieser Büsow da tatsächlich irgendwie in einer dermaßener Hartnädigkeit enttalligt und tatsächlich anfängt, irgendwelche Internetprovider zu zwingen, irgendwie Sturmgesetze aus dem Netz zu nehmen.
Kann er das denn überhaupt? Also ich meine, wie zwingt der die denn?
Ja, er beruft sich auf den Mediendienst des Staatsvertrags. Es hat ja damals, muss man dazu sagen, in Deutschland gibt es zwei Internetgesetze. Das eine ist das Tele-Dienste-Gesetz und das andere ist der Mediendienst des Staatsvertrags. Und das ist entstanden historisch dadurch, dass man im Bundestag zusammengesessen hat und überlegt hat, man braucht jetzt irgendwie Gesetze, um diese Verantwortlichkeiten zu regeln. Wofür sind die ASBs verantwortlich, wofür nicht und so fort. Und dann hat man, wie das in Deutschland so üblich ist, sich ewig gestritten, und zwar zwischen Bund und Ländern. Die SPD hat dann irgendwie so ein Gesetz geschrieben, den Tele-Dienste-Gesetz, und das wollten sie genehmigt haben. Und dazu brauchten sie die Mehrheit im Bundesrat. Im Bundesrat sitzen aber die Vertreter der Länder. Und die waren irgendwie, ne, das war irgendwie auch SPD war da die Mehrheit oder irgendein Schnickschnack. Und die haben dann aber so eine, ja, Erpressung könnte man in anderen Kontexten sagen. In der Politik gibt es da höflichere Begriffe für, aber es lief jedenfalls darauf. Ah, Konsens hieß er. Alles klar, jedenfalls lief es darauf hinaus, dass die Länder auch was zum Regeln haben wollten. Und deswegen gibt es zweimal fast das wortgleiche Gesetz, einmal für den Bund und einmal für die Länder. Und da steht drin, dass die Provider im Grunde genommen nicht verantwortlich sind, es sei denn, es ist ihn und jetzt kommt der schwierige Begriff zumutbar, entsprechende Inhalte zu sperren. Im Begriff der Zumutbarkeit kann man jetzt irgendwie, das ist so ein Gummischeiß, da kann man irgendwie dehnen und dran ziehen und so weiter und so fort. Und bisher haben alle gesagt, das ist nicht nur nicht zumutbar, sondern es ist auch völliger Schwachsinn, weil es sich viel zu leicht umgehen lässt, wenn man im Internet filtert. Und der Herr Büsow, der Bezirksregierungspräsident von Düsseldorf sagt jetzt halt, naja, es ist sehr wohl zumutbar, einzelne DNS-Einträge zu sperren. Darunter halt irgendwie, also mit Rock'n'Corn hat er angefangen und dann, ich weiß gar nicht, was seine aktuelle Sperrliste ist. Da gibt es irgendwie NSD, APO oder irgendeinem Blödsinnpunkt, irgendetwas. Also irgendwelche Fachhochseits halt. Und er sagt halt, das lässt sich irgendwie sehr wohl durchführen. Er hat dann den Provider.
Der glaubt auch wirklich, das Problem wäre dann weg.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, genau. Der fühlt sich auch berufen und das ist natürlich im Grunde genommen ist das ein Testlauf. Und er sagt dann immer, ja wissen Sie, die Gesetze in Deutschland, die schreiben das ja vor, was ich tue. Also wir haben ja letzte Woche war ich mit dem Jens Ohlig, mit dem anderen Sitzesprecher bei ihm. Und er sagte dann immer so, ja wissen Sie, wir müssen mal an die Gesetze halten. Und er fragt dann auch immer so, was machen die denn gegen Nazis? Also sind sie denn wirklich für Nazi Propaganda? Auf diese Argumentation wollte er es dann runterbrechen. Und dazu gibt es aber eine wunderschöne Geschichte über Herrn Büsow. Der war nämlich im Dezember letzten Jahres bei einem Martinsgansessen der Deutschen Bank. Und da hat der Herr Spiegel geredet, dieser Vorsitzende des Zentrals der Arzt der Juden. Der hat da eine Rede gehalten und danach haben sich ein paar Leute dort geäußert, unter anderem ein dort ansässiger Rechtsanwalt, dessen Name ich gleich mal raussuchen könnte. Und der hat irgendwie so Sätze gesagt, also vor versammelter Mannschaft, nach dem Essen, so Ja, also Herr Spiegel, wissen Sie, durch Ihre öffentlichen Auftritte sind Sie es ja, die dem Antisemitismus hier überhaupt nur irgendwie Auftrieb verleihen und bla bla bla. Und er selbst, dieser Anwalt, hätte also neben dem KZ-Ausschwitz gearbeitet als Kanonier und wäre verschiedentlich ins Konzentrationslager zum Duschen gefahren. Und er hätte also jene Menge Juden gesehen, aber keine Goldentaten der Nazis. Und also, also wirklich Hardcore-Scheiß, Entschuldigung, hat der da geredet. Und das Lustige ist halt, dass Herr Büsow, der saß halt im Raum und hat gar nichts gemacht. Es gab andere Leute, die dann...
Vielleicht ist Herr Büsow ja genauso für Nazi-Propaganda wie der CCC. Also laut Herrn Büsow.
Ja, also ich meine, er meinte das halt immer so von wegen, wenn wir dagegen sind, Nazi-Propaganda zu filtern, dann sind wir ja für die Verbreitung von Nazi-Propaganda, also der Umkehrschluss. Die Frage ist halt, wenn man jetzt sagt, ist Nazi-Propaganda erstens ein Problem, oder sind es nicht vielleicht die Nazis selbst, die ein Problem sind, und vor allem löst man das Problem dadurch, dass man es halt wegfiltert. Wenn man das hier so in der SPA machen könnte, beispielsweise in Berlin immer Umland oder so, das wäre irgendwie eine Maßnahme.
Das grundsätzliche Problem ist halt, dass es in Deutschland halt irgendwie diese spezifischen, speziellen Gesetze gibt, die halt irgendwie gerade irgendwie im Nazi-Punkt halt irgendwie einige Dinge spezifisch unter Strafe stellen, aus historischen Gründen, die halt in Amerika zum Beispiel total egal sind. Und die Frage dabei ist dann halt letzten Endes irgendwie, ist das eigentlich noch irgendwie sinnvoll und zeitgemäß oder ist das jetzt eine Sache, über die man auch mal irgendwie nachdenken und reden muss, wie es eigentlich mit der Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland wirklich bestellt ist?
Ja, es ist natürlich auch immer wieder ein gern genommenes Argument von irgendwelchen rechten Schwachsinnigen, die auf Meinungsfreiheit zu berufen und dann da wirklich komplett über die Stränge zu schlagen und insbesondere junge Menschen zu agitieren, die dann wirklich nicht die, ich sag mal über die geistige Kapazität verfügen, da zu unterscheiden. Da bist du wirklich auf einer Garte.
Ja, aber es ist halt das Eingestimmte, dass diese Gesellschaft nicht erwachsen ist.
Das ist richtig, das ist eine sehr unreife Gesellschaft, das stimmt.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich irgendwie so eine Kindergartenangelegenheit.
Chaosradio 70, die Musik kommt übrigens die ganze Zeit, also weitestgehend von einem Sampler namens Asia Lounge. Nur so für den Fall, dass sie euch das fragen.
Aber das werden wir gleich ändern.
Hören wir, ja das will ich sehen. Zeig mal.
Kann ich mal wieder?
Ich bin ein bürschchen.
Wir haben jetzt ja noch jemand am Telefon.
Ja das haben wir in der Tat.
Und zwar wir planen ja diese Demonstrationen oder vielmehr die eigentliche Plane macht, der RK aus Köln und deswegen haben wir jetzt den Ingo aus Köln am Telefon. Genau und die hören jetzt irgendwie möglicherweise unsere Hörer, so wie wir welche haben.
Na ich hoffe, es hören uns Demonstranten nicht wahr?
Ja potenziell.
Demonstrationsaufrufe, wir können uns jetzt gerne über Demonstrationsaufrufe im öffentlich rechtlichen deutschen Tonrundfunk unterhalten. Das ist nämlich untersagt. Aber egal.
Wir wollen da auch gar nicht, dass er hier, nein, nein, nein, wir machen ja keine Agitation. Ne, ne, ne.
Wie? Wie? Wir planen im Grunde einen Straßenfest für die Internetfreiheit.
Ah. Und wie sieht das dann aus?
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Sachen, so verschiedene Modelle. Also ich denke, es wird auf jeden Fall spaßig werden. Wenn wir es hinkriegen und das sieht ganz gut aus, dann wird es eine komplette Hackparade geben.
Wann und wo?
Die Hackparade wird in Düsseldorf sein. Das ist am 6. April. Das ist ein Samstag. Direkt der übernächste Samstag.
Aber warum denn in Düsseldorf?
Weil da eben dieser Herr Düsseldorf ist. Und jetzt aber mal für den Fritz-Radio-Hörer, was ist denn eine Hackparade? Wir kennen ja in Berlin ja nur die Love-Parade und das ist ja an der Karneval für...
Die ja dieses Jahr unter dem Motto stehen wird, Access Freedom.
Wir verschiedene Wagen nehmen und darauf ganz viele Hacker sitzen. Und die werden dann verrückte Sachen auf ihren Wagen machen. Und ich denke, das wird sich dann alles auf der Parade selber zeigen, was da alles passieren wird.
Und die 4 Millionen Teilnehmer erwartet ihr?
Na ja, ist ein bisschen schwierig abzuschätzen. Das ist die allererste Demonstration, die wir vom Chaos Computer Club machen. Es ist sicherlich ein Novum. Als es losging, haben wir noch 400 Teilnehmer bei der Polizei angegeben. Aber jetzt bei der Medienreaktion, die wir da bekommen haben, das könnten glatt mehr werden.
Und wird es Internet geben?
Es ist noch in der Schwebe, aber ich denke, da wird es auf jeden Fall was geben. Es gibt da gewisse Leute in Berlin, die planen, eine Webcam aufzubauen und es damit dann live ins Netz zu streamen. Es wird natürlich dann auch im IRC eine Berichterstattung geben. Und ja, alles andere. Kann man gespannt sein.
Werdet ihr da auch so rituelle alte Hardware-Verbrennungen vor dem Regierungspräsidium machen oder sowas?
Das wird bestimmt Umweltverschmutzung.
Das ist eine lustige Idee. Das könnte man eigentlich mal blatt anplanen.
Dann muss man nur den dioxinhaltigen Rauch richten.
Wie heißt dieser RP da in Düsseldorf?
Du meinst jetzt dieses chinesische Diskettensägen-Massaker?
Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Einfach mal alte Hardware beim Regierungspräsidenten abladen.
Hier, nimm, komm. Man muss sich nicht so vorstellen, dass der Regierungspräsident an einer stark befahrenen Straße ist. Dahinter ist so eine kleine Parkanlage. Inwieweit man da Feuer machen kann, wird sich zeigen.
Führt der Demonstrationszug dorthin oder dort dann vorbei?
Wir werden in der Innenstadt von Düsseldorf starten.
Und zwar um 14 Uhr am Gustav-Grünkens-Platz. Das ist für die Düsseldorfer unter uns der Platz vor dem Schauspielhaus. Darunter kennen die Düsseldorfer das.
Um 14 Uhr starten wir, gehen dann durch die Fußgängerzone, ein Stück entlang an der Kö, dann durch die Altstadt, dann am Schlosturm vorbei und schließlich den Rhein entlang, direkt bis zur Bezirksregierung.
Juhaia.
Ist das eine attraktive Demonstrationsstrecke?
Rein optisch.
Sehr angenehm.
Eine wunderbar romantische Spaziergangsstrecke.
Schön Rheinuferpromenade, das ist wirklich ganz toll. Viel weiter dürfen sie auch nicht gehen, weil dann kommen die ganzen Botschaften, wo die Bullen vorumlungern.
Na ja, es kommt schon noch so hin mit Bannmeile und so weiter. Es gibt da ja gewisse Regeln, wo man sich halten muss.
Das ist natürlich dann schon mit der Polizei abgeklümmelt.
Aber das kommt so alles noch hin.
Wie man jetzt mittlerweile aus der Pistole weiß. Das ist ja eine relative Umgangsform dort.
Wo ist das nicht?
In Berlin heißt das Landowski.
Ja, da gibt es noch keinen Werb für.
Da gibt es da gewisse kulturelle Unterschiede.
Genau, ein bisschen Kölsch draufkippen, dann gibt es schon.
Aber nur in der Form, nicht in der Sache denke ich.
Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall auf eine schöne Demo.
Am nächsten Samstag ab 14 Uhr in Düsseldorf. Am übernächsten Samstag ab 14 Uhr in Düsseldorf. Am Gustav-Feinemann-Platz? Am Gustav-Gründkens-Platz.
Ich kann ja noch mal die URL durch.
Und zwar unter www.netzzensur.de Da findet man eigentlich alles, was man braucht, um dorthin zu finden.
www.netzzensur oder netzzensur?
Also mit Doppel Z.
Netzzensur.de Alles klar. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Viel Erfolg, ich wünsche dir Entschuldigung. Und danke für das Gespräch.
Ja, ich möchte...
Was? Ja, Chaosradio 70.
Hallo? Ich glaube, jetzt ist er dran.
Das haben wir so schlecht behandelt. Kannst du mir eine Mail schicken, dass das irgendwie nicht so gemeint war, wie wir das gesagt haben?
Ja, das kann ich gleich mal tun, aber euer Internet ist ja hier...
Wie unser Internet? Das ist nicht unser Internet, das ist dein Internet. Das ist euer Internet, wir surfen nur drin rum.
Voll digitales Videos enthekbar, so ein internet Simulationsextrakt.
Chaosradio 70 auf Fritz. Wie war das? Der Zustand des Internets dieser Tage war unser Thema heute.
Ja und Netzzensur und so den ganzen Kram. Wir haben jetzt ja am Telefon noch den Alvar Freude. Der hat in zwei Sachen mit diesem Thema zu tun. Zum einen hat er mal so ein Experiment durchgeführt. Hört der uns eigentlich schon?
Ja, ich bin dran.
Du kannst ja mal über dieses Inside-Coin-Spielchen ein bisschen berichten, weil das hat da im Grunde auch mit diesem Zensurthema zu tun.
Moment, das ist der Erfinder des Münzautomaten?
Ich habe zusammen mit dem Tragan Espenschied Mitschüdenzen zu unserer Diplomarbeit ein Experiment durchgeführt, wo wir feststellen wollten, wie die Leute auf Zensur reagieren. Das heißt, wir haben drei Fragestellungen gehabt. Wie einfach ist es überhaupt, ein umfangreiches Zensursystem zu programmieren, was nicht nur irgendwelche Webseiten blockiert, sondern wirklich die Inhalte austauscht? Das ist eigentlich relativ einfach. Wir haben es innerhalb von ein paar Wochen hinbekommen. Und das haben wir in der ganzen Akademie, wo wir studiert haben, das ist die Märzakademie in Stuttgart, 250 Studenten, haben wir das an allen Studentenrechern eingestellt.
Mit Wissen der Studenten oder ohne? Wussten die Studenten das oder wussten die das?
Das ging alles im Geheimen. Nur unsere Professorin wusste davon und wir wussten davon. Sonst niemand, noch nicht mal die Techniker im Haus. Und die zweite Frage war natürlich, wie reagieren die Studenten? Merken die überhaupt, wenn da Helmut Kohl gegen Gerhard Schröder ausgetauscht wird oder in ihren E-Mails und einmal irgendwelche Sachen verändert werden? Weil die meisten, die können kein E-Mail Programm bedienen und lesen deswegen über GMX oder ähnliches.
Und du meinst Helmut Kohl gegen Gerhard Schröder ausgetauscht, wenn ich jetzt zu Spiegel Online surfe, steht da auf einmal nicht Gerhard Schröder hat gesagt, sondern Helmut Kohl hat gesagt.
Also da gibt es ein klassisches Beispiel. Irgendeiner hat es mal gesehen, dass auf Spiegel Online wirklich dran steht, dass Gerhard Schröder, sein Ex-Kanzler Gerhard Schröder seine Memoiren schreibt und dass auch Bundeskanzler Kohl demnächst seine Memoiren veröffentlichen wird. Und der war noch etwas verwirrt da drüber, aber kam natürlich nie auf die Idee, dass das irgendjemand manipuliert haben könnte. Und hat gedacht, na gut, die Spiegel haben halt einen Fehler gemacht. Und es war aber auch die einzige Sache, die aufgefallen ist.
Kannst du mal noch was dazu sagen, wie ihr es technisch gemacht habt?
Wir haben ein Proxy programmiert. Also ein Proxy, das normalerweise wird es benutzt, um das Netz ein bisschen schneller zu machen, dass Daten, die schon mal da sind, zwischengespeichert werden. Und den kann man natürlich auch prima nutzen, um Daten zu filtern und um die zu verändern. Und wir haben dann die volle Kontrolle dazu, um Webdaten zu filtern. Also wir haben absichtlich natürlich keine normalen E-Mails gefiltert, auch keine verschlüsselten Verbindungen, sondern nur ganz stinknormales Web. Aber das reicht für die meisten Fälle ja auch. Und naja, die Leute haben es nicht gemerkt. Wir sind zum Schluss wirklich an die Grenzen unserer Vorstellungskraft gelangt. Was wir alles noch machen können. Also wir haben wirklich hunderte von Veränderungen gemacht. Wer will, kann das alles ausprobieren. Unter odem.org, www.odem.org gibt es ein Menüpunkt Insert Coin. Und da steht alles dazu dran. Da steht auch wie man den Proxy einstellt, wie man das alles mal nachvollziehen kann.
Wie hätte ich denn, also wie hätte ich jetzt als unbedarfter User überhaupt merken können, dass manipuliert wurde? Also weil ich gehe nach wie vor davon aus, dass Spiegel Online einfach einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Wir haben viele kleine Anspielungen reingesetzt. Also wir haben zum Beispiel Werbebanner, Zwangswerbebanner auf zwei Prozent aller Seiten gesetzt. Und zwar wurde die gesamte Seite einfach durch eine Werbung ersetzt. Und da waren kleine Anspielungen drin, wo man stutzig werden musste. Oder bei GMX und bei anderen Freemail-Diensten haben wir einen ganzen Kasten eingeblendet, wo man Brieffreunde quasi kriegen konnte angeblich. Und da stand unten so dran, ja, dieser Brieffreund wurde exklusiv für sie aufgrund ihrer persönlichen Einschwerdung und Surfgewohnheiten ausgesucht. Und da hätten natürlich die Leute skeptisch werden müssen, aber irgendwie hat das keine Sau interessiert.
Und was haben die gesagt als Hinterherfahren?
Nicht viel, das ist ja das Interessante, das ist nämlich der dritte Punkt. Das Ding ist irgendwann aufgeflogen, weil unser Server ausgefallen ist, einen halben Tag lang. Und dann ging halt im ganzen Haus kein Internet mehr, weil für die Leute ist das WWW-Internet. Und dann gingen sie zu den Assistenten und die wussten auch überhaupt nichts und haben ewig gesucht, bis sie das mal gefunden haben. Weil bei ihnen ging es noch, wir haben nur die Studentenrechner manipuliert, vor den Proxy halt eingestellt. Und dann haben wir das irgendwann rausgekriegt, dann ging eine Rundmail rum an alle, wir haben denen das nochmal erklärt, wir haben da so ein paar Heckvorwürfe gekriegt und so weiter. Dann haben wir das nochmal erklärt, was wir da gemacht haben und eine Schritt für Schritt Anleitung veröffentlicht. Und die wurde von den Studenten gerade von drei Studenten angeschaut. Das heißt, gerade mal drei Leute hatten überhaupt Interesse, an ungefiltertes Internet zu kommen. Das ganze Ding war noch ungefähr drei Monate nachdem das öffentlich war online. Und auch da war die Diplomarbeit, haben wir schon öffentlich präsentiert und alles mögliche. Und die Leute haben den Filter einfach nicht aufgeschaltet. Da gab es so Sachen, dass Leute zu uns kamen, ja, ich hab da was gehört, ihr macht doch da so einen Filter und so. Und ich habe hier eine Bewerbung und ich will mich für das Praxismesser in New York bewerben und so. Und andauernd meine Seiten werden verändert. Ist das bei denen in New York auch so? Und dann hatte Dragan dem gesagt, nö, das ist in New York nicht so. Und wollte ihm erklären, wie er auch selbst an ungefilterte Seiten rankommen konnte. Aber es hat ihn gar nicht mehr interessiert. Es war ihm egal. Weil wir gedacht haben, na gut, Hauptsache, die in New York kriegen, meine Seite ungefiltert. Aber was ich kriege, ist mir egal. Also das ist ein bisschen so eine fatalistische Einstellung, die sich da herausgebildet hat. Ich mache ja sowieso nichts Wichtiges im Netz. Und das ist alles nicht so kritisch, denken viele. Und ich hab nichts zu verbergen. Also ich denke, das ist natürlich kein groß angelegtes Experiment. 250 Leute ist nicht viel. Aber wenn man das mit Tier-Online machen würde, würde das Ergebnis sicherlich nicht großartig anders ausfallen.
Ich denke mal, das 250 angehende Akademiker, oder nennt man Studenten eigentlich auch Akademiker, gehört jetzt nicht hin. Ich denke mal, dass 250 Studenten da schon eine relativ große Masse sind. Weil ich sag mal, der TED, also der Deutsche Durchschnittsbürger, der wird es ja noch weniger merken. Also der merkt ja noch nicht mal, was in der Bildzeitung für einen Unsinn steht.
Ja gut, aber der Unterschied zwischen Gerhard Kohle und Helmut Schröder, der ist ja mittlerweile auch wirklich schwer festzustellen.
Ja, also gut zu Kohle und Schröder muss man sagen, die Leute haben natürlich wenig irgendwelche politischen Seiten angeschaut. Was sie angeschaut haben, ist irgendwelche tollen Flash-Animationen. Das ist eine Kunst-Grafik-Design-Medientheorie-Hochschule. Alles in allem so ein bisschen. Oder Bewerbungen für Australien, weil sie alle ins Praxisemester nach Australien wollten. Das war auch ganz interessant. Da haben wir gesagt, naja, die Leute schauen alle australische Websites an. Und in Australien gab es ja gerade so ein Zensurgesetz, dass jeder einen privaten Filter sich installieren muss. Und dann haben wir gesagt, na gut, wir erfinden einfach, dass die australischen Provider sich dagegen wehen und haben komplett alle australischen Websites geblockt quasi. Und dann kamen die Leute nur auf so eine Erklärung, ja, wir die australischen Provider, wir protestieren dagegen und so weiter. Und hier könnt ihr Feedback geben. Und das hat auch keinen interessiert. Die Leute haben es halt akzeptiert und Tschüss und weg. Also, das ist da eine sehr oberflächliche Haltung zu dem Thema.
Kann es sein, dass es vielleicht einfach so ein Wahrnehmungsunterschied ist, dass das irgendwie so wir empfinden es ja als mittlere Katastrophe, wenn das Internet mal weg ist oder irgendwie ein Problem hat? Kann es sein, dass es einfach vielen, vielen Leuten nicht so geht?
Das natürlich auch. Also es ist interessant, wir haben im Herbst einen Medienkunstpreis vom ZKM und SWR dafür gewonnen und die kamen dann her und haben mit den Studenten ein paar Interviews gemacht und gedreht. Und bei diesem Dreh kamen sehr interessante Statements rüber, weil auch die Leute zuerst gesagt haben, naja gut, es interessiert mich nicht wirklich, ich mache nichts Wichtiges, ist nicht weiter schlimm, wenn da ein bisschen was passiert und so. Und zwar ja eine Diplomarbeit und bla bla. Und ist ja alles ganz lustig. Aber dann kam halt dann die Frage, ja aber du recherchierst doch für deine Studienarbeiten im Netz oder machst du das nicht? Und dann, naja, mache ich eigentlich schon. Und wenn da natürlich manipulierte Inhalte dabei rauskommen, ist das natürlich ein bisschen kritisch. Also es ist einfach dem Normalanwender wahrscheinlich noch nicht so bewusst, was er da überhaupt macht. Also die Authentizität kommt durch die Adresse, durch die URL oben im Browser und was da letztendlich darunter passiert, das wird auch überhaupt nicht verstanden. Das ist viel zu kompliziert. Da hat keiner Lust, die Proxie-Einstellung hat von den Leuten kein einziger jemals gesehen. Vielleicht einer oder zwei Leute, aber sonst niemand.
Habt ihr eigentlich im Rahmen der Auswertung mal so generelle Fragen zur Glaubwürdigkeit von Internetseiten gestellt? Also wie sozusagen die subjektive Glaubwürdigkeit von Information, was im Internet überhaupt ist?
Das kommt bei den Leuten ganz stark drauf an, auf welche Seite sie gehen. Also wenn seriöse, bekannte Medien sind, Spiegel online oder sowas, das ist schon glaubwürdig. Aber eine private Homepage, das ist natürlich genauso glaubwürdig, wie wenn einer auf der Straße einem was erzählt. Also da ist die Sache schon da, dass die Leute das verstehen. Also man kann da auch ganz interessante Effekte erzielen. Also wenn wir manchmal auf irgendwelchen Medienkunstfestivals waren, dann haben wir einfach in der Media-Launch, wenn da ein paar Rechner rumstanden, den Proxy eingestellt. Und dann haben die Leute gefiltertes Zeug gekriegt. Und da wir alte Flashhaster sind, haben wir natürlich einen Filter, der Flashfilme gegen irgendeinen Nonsens austauscht. Und es ist super interessant, wenn man dann irgendwelche so Pseudomedien-Künstler und sowas ähnliches sieht, die dann das sehen und dann ganz ehrfürchtig davor stehen, wenn sie eine Seite aufrufen, wo sie denken, dass irgendwas Tolles kommt. Und dann kommt irgendwas Banales und dann merken sie nicht, dass es wirklich was Banales ist.
Wie bist du eigentlich zu dem Thema oder zu Herrn Büsow gekommen?
Also Büsow nochmal für die, die sich zugeschaltet haben, Regierungspräsident von Düsseldorf. Der Regierungspräsident von Düsseldorf möchte ganz gerne, bzw. versucht gerade zu zwingen, nordrhein-westfälische Internetprovider bestimmte Webseiten zu sperren, also insbesondere rechtsradikale oder wie auch immer gearteten anstößigen Inhalts. Also diese Seiten sollten dann auch im Ausland liegen, damit sie gesperrt werden können, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Genau so im Prinzip. Also ich oder wir beide, der Dragan und ich, haben uns ja schon lange mit dem Thema Zensur und Machtstruktur mit Internet beschäftigt. Deswegen haben wir ja auch das InsertCoin gemacht, was jetzt nicht nur aus dem Experiment und auch aus dem großen theoretischen Teil besteht. Und naja, als diese BISO-Geschichte immer konkreter wurde, war das natürlich bei uns auch bekannt. Und da habe ich mich natürlich auch weiter informiert. Ich hatte dann Strafanzeige gegen Herrn BISO und gegen ein paar Provider gestellt, die bevor die Sperrverfügung rauskam, schon manche Seiten gefiltert haben, weil ich der Ansicht bin, dass sie durch gegen das Fernmeldegeheimnis verstoßen. Indem sie einfach E-Mails umleiten.
Ach, das machen die auch?
Das machen die auch, genau. Also die derzeitigen Filtermechanismen, die die im Moment haben, das wird sich in ein paar Monaten möglicherweise ändern, wenn diese Boca-Tel-Webwasher-Geschichte da ist. Aber derzeit werden einfach alle Daten gefiltert, inklusive E-Mails. Die kommen einfach nicht an oder können an jemand anderes umgeleitet werden.
Das heißt, E-Mails zu bestimmten Domains filtern die ja schon?
Genau, ja. Und da habe ich mich natürlich mit dem Thema immer mehr beschäftigt.
Wie hat denn die Staatsanwaltschaft darauf reagiert?
Am Anfang waren die erstmal etwas komisch. Also ich hatte von verschiedenen Journalisten, mit denen ich gesprochen hatte, gehört, dass die dann gefragt haben, ja kennen sie diesen Freude überhaupt? Wer ist denn das? Ist das ein Nazi und so? Und ich meine, das ist natürlich die erste Reaktion, wenn jemand irgendwelche Sachen oft scheinbar verteidigt, die von Nazis kommen. Es geht ja am Anfang um Nazi Websites, da ist ein gesellschaftlicher Konsens da, dass die böse sind. Ist ja auch richtig.
Und jeder, der für Informationsfreiheit kämpft, ist natürlich erstmal unterm Faschismus verdachten. Genau, genau. Liberale Gesellschaft hier, ja.
Und dass hier nur die Befürchtung da ist, dass das in ein paar Wochen ganz andere Dimensionen angeht, ist sehr schwierig zu verstehen für die meisten Leute. Ja, und dann waren die erstmal etwas verwundert, was da überhaupt ist, haben dann ein bisschen ermittelt und kamen zu unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen. Also in Düsseldorf kamen die zu dem Ergebnis, dass zwar E-Mails und das Fernmeld der Geheimnis fallen, dass aber da die E-Mails teilweise zumindest wieder zurückgeschickt wurden, würde das nicht eine Verletzung des Fernmeldegeheimnisses sein.
Und damit hast du dich zufrieden gegeben?
Ich habe mich vorerst damit mal zufrieden gegeben, weil ich meine, es ist natürlich eine sehr kritische Sache und das war jetzt mal ein Versuch, wenn man da nochmal neue Erkenntnisse hat, kann sicherlich jemand anderes nochmal eine Strafanzeige stellen. Ich hätte Widerspruch einlegen können. In Düsseldorf gab es keine Frist, möglicherweise kann ich das noch, aber ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich es machen will. Das interessante ist, dass die Antwort aus Köln lautete, E-Mails würden nicht dem Fernmeldegeheimnis unterliegen, weil E-Mails kein körperlicher Gegenstand seien.
Interessant.
Das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Das heißt, die gesamte Urheberrechtsdebatte wäre ja auch dann hinfällig.
Vor allen Dingen werden Telefongespräche auch keine körperlichen Gegenstände.
Genau, ein Telefongespräch oder ein Fax und so weiter. Also das ist natürlich ein an Haaren herbeigezogenes Argument.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man denen einfach nur eine Müllverbrennungsanlage dahinstellen, dann sind die auf deiner Seite.
Ja, und ich hatte auch einfach jetzt mit Widerspruch, es war mir jetzt nicht so wichtig wie die anderen Aktionen, die wir am Laufen haben, weil letztendlich ist die Frage mit was man am meisten erreicht und die Ressourcen natürlich auch knapp. Ich muss auch irgendwie gucken, wie ich mit der Zeit zurechtkomme. Und wir haben jetzt hier von der Gruppe Odem Org, auch mit Unterstützung von paar CCC-Lern eine Unterschriften-Sammlung ins Leben gerufen, wo wir Unterschriften für die Einhaltung der Informationsfreiheit sammeln. Da gibt es eine etwas längere Erklärung dazu, wo wir das auch begründen. Wir haben Erstunterzeichner, zum Beispiel die Reporter ohne Grenzen oder Andy ist auch dabei. Wir haben den SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneten Jörg Taus, das ist der Internet-Experte von denen und seine Kollegin von den Grünen, die Gritje Betin, sind auch bei den Erstunterzeichnern dabei. Also das sind alles hochkarätige Leute, denen man auch nicht mehr vorwerfen kann, die würden irgendwie Rechtsextremismus unterstützen wollen. Und ja, da sind wir kräftig am Sammeln von Unterschriften.
Auch zu finden auf odem.org.
Das ist auch auf www.odem.org. Da gibt es dann gleich am Anfang einen Link, wo das drauf steht. Ja, da kann man auch diskutieren. Also jeder, der seine Unterschrift abgibt, gibt einen Kommentar gleichzeitig mit ab, kann was dazu sagen und den kann man dann wieder kommentieren und so weiter.
Ja, wunderschön. Das war es auch nur, was wir erstmal als Eindruck von Herrn Harmold. Das sei dann, dir liegt jetzt noch was. Ich meine, siehst du jetzt noch sozusagen, wie das an der juristischen Front weitergeht. Es ist ja so, der Herr Büsow hat, wenn ich den Status richtig sehe, die Sperrverfügung jetzt im Februar rausgeschickt. Und es gibt jetzt etliche Widersprüche, die, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann wird erst mal verwaltungsgerichtlich behandelt werden.
Genau. Also es ist da so...
Hast du da einen Überblick, wie viele...
Das Paradoxe ist ja, dass der Büsow als ernanmter Beamter, der ist ja nicht gewählt, das ist ein Verwaltungsbeamter, dass der eine Sperrverfügung an die Provider rausschickt, die überhaupt kein Interesse eigentlich an diesen Sachen, die gesperrt werden, haben. Weil das sind ja nicht die Inhaltsanbieter, sondern das sind nur die Datentransporteure und was da transportiert wird, ist denen wurscht. Die müssen sich aber damit rumschlagen. Und wenn die dagegen sind, weil sie das einfach moralisch nicht vertreten können, dann müssen sie sich wehren. Aber sie haben eigentlich kein wirkliches Interesse daran. Das ist eigentlich nur Idealismus, kann man sagen, wenn die sich dagegen wehren.
Gibt es denn in Nordrhein-Westfalen irgendeinen Provider, der sagt, den Mist mach ich nicht mit?
Ja, und da gibt es mehrere, die Einspruch eingelegt haben. Die Frist ist ja schon eine Weile abgelaufen. Also mindestens zwei, aber ich hab gehört, dass es die Mehrheit sein soll, die die Einspruch eingelegt hat. Mit ganz verschiedenen Begründungen. Das interessante ist, dass dieser Einspruch an die gleiche Verwaltungsbehörde geht, die die Verfügung erlassen hat. Weil es in Nordrhein-Westfalen keine übergeordnete Behörde mehr gibt, die dafür zuständig ist. Das heißt, diese Behörde wird natürlich in Einspruch wieder abweisen. Weil sonst hätte sie ja gar nicht die Verfügung erstellt. Und nach diesem Einspruch, danach kann dagegen geklagt werden. Das ist natürlich auch eine finanzielle Frage. Da muss man erst mal bereit sein, dagegen zu klagen und vorher auch einen Anwalt beauftragen und so weiter.
Spätestens wenn der erste Provider anfängt, wirklich massiv Kunden zu verlieren, dann ist ja die Zumutbarkeitsgrenze erreicht und dann können die sich überlegen, was sie tun.
Am Anfang ist es natürlich so mit den Kunden, es geht im Augenblick um zwei Domains. Das ist an sich natürlich noch nicht so schlimm. Schlimm wird es erst, wenn die ihr Filtersystem, ihre Blackbox haben, diese bei allen Providern, die eine Auslandsleitung haben, hinstellen und dann zwangsweise alles darüber geht, die Provider überhaupt nicht mehr wissen, was gefiltert wird und...
Vor allen Dingen denke ich mal, es ist irgendwie wichtig, dass irgendwie dieser Begriff der Zumutbarkeit dann möglicherweise als angenommen werden kann. Also wenn es technische Mittel und Wege gibt, die erstmal suggerieren, dass man tatsächlich erfolgreich filtern kann, dann ist natürlich klar, dass irgendwie der Druck auf andere Provider außerhalb von Nordrhein-Westfalen entstehen wird.
Eben, genau. Ich meine, das ist ein Versuchsballon. Und Nazi-Webseite sind dazu natürlich gut, weil da ist der gesellschaftliche Konsens da, dass man das nicht haben will. Und es ist auch vollkommen legitim, wenn die aus Deutschland kommen, aber wenn die aus dem Ausland kommen, will ich mich natürlich darüber informieren können. Das ist ja wohl ganz klar, weil...
Moment, man muss ja sagen, die gesetzlichen Grundlagen, die sozusagen das Inland betreffen, die betreffen ja in der Regel auch den Sender, sozusagen nicht den Transporteur. Also selbst da heißt es ja nicht, dass die Leute filtern oder zensieren sollen, sondern da heißt es, dass derjenige, der die Sachen anbietet, eben entsprechend weg ist, bzw. dafür eben strafrechtlich verantwortlich gemacht werden kann.
Genau, und das ist ja im Großen und Ganzen auch okay. Um Details kann man da sicherlich immer darüber streiten, wie weit man das haben will. Aber wenn das aus dem Ausland kommt, ist es eine Art Feindsenderverbot. Da ist jemand, der hat irgendwas Unerwünschtes und den will man verbieten. Das ist natürlich eine DDR-Methode.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn es einem Verwaltungsbeamten obliegt zu bestimmen, was jetzt unerwünscht ist und was nicht unerwünscht ist.
Eben, genau. Und ich meine, die Liste von dem, was da noch kommen soll, ist lang. Also zum Beispiel in der Sperrverfügung sind schon Suchmaschinen erwähnt. Ganz eindeutig. Da steht drin, Suchmaschinen sind weitere potenzielle nächste Kandidaten für Sperrverfügungen. Weil zum Beispiel Google einen Cash hat, in dem man auch die Seiten abrufen kann oder überhaupt man die finden kann, die Seiten. Ihr habt ja vielleicht gehört, vor ein paar Tagen ging rum, Google hat Scientology-Seite aus dem Index genommen, eine kritische Seite von Scientology, weil dadurch angeblich das Urheberrecht verletzt wird. Das heißt, Scientology versucht mit der Keule des Urheberrechts wieder Kritiker-Mundtot zu machen. Das ist für so ein Filter natürlich auch wieder glücklich.
Eine weitere Interessengruppe.
Dann wird sich Nordrhein-Westfalen wahrscheinlich als erstes hinten anstellen, wenn es um Fortschritt geht, oder?
Ja, das kommt natürlich auf Dauer an.
Das wird Clement irgendwann auch mal merken. Eco hat ja auch schon entsprechend protestiert und so fort. Die tun das natürlich in der Tat aus wirtschaftlichen Gründenweise sagen, es kann nicht sein, dass die Kunden uns dann eben in andere Bundesländer abfahren, weil die ihre technischen Strukturen dorthin aufbauen.
Das ist ein ganz kompliziertes Thema und in der Öffentlichkeit ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig zu vermitteln, weil da ist es natürlich die gängige Ansicht, was ja auch im Prinzip okay ist, wer was gegen Nazis macht, ist es auch gut und richtig. Nur letztendlich wird hier nichts gegen Nazis unternommen, weil die Nazis kommen ran. Umgehend kann man die sperren, wenn man weiß wie.
Es ist wie ein NPD-Verbot, damit ist das Problem nicht aus der Welt.
Ja, es ist noch was anderes als ein NPD-Verbot. Beim NPD-Verbot wird ja wirklich ein Teil von der Partei aufgelöst und Vermögen eingezogen und so weiter und so fort. Aber hier ist es einfach, wenn man den Leuten die Augen zuhält, die NPD nicht verbietet, sondern ihnen die Augen zuhält, dass sie die NPD nicht mehr sehen können.
Vielleicht ja, dann doch eher so. Ich vermute mal alles, worüber wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben, ist auch auf odem.org nachzulesen.
Mehr oder weniger, ja. Die Details ist natürlich immer ein bisschen schwierig. Muss jemand schreiben und so weiter. Aber die Sachen sind nachzulesen. Wir haben auch eine Liste mit häufig gestellten Fragen auf dem Zensurteil von der Seite, wo nochmal so ein paar übliche Vorurteile aufgegriffen werden.
Alles klar. Okay, tausend Dank. Wir diskutieren jetzt noch ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist nämlich Chaosradio 70 hier und wir sprechen über den Zustand des Internets, insbesondere Zensur des Internets, so wie Nordrhein-Westfalen bzw. der Düsseldorfer Regierungspräsident es derzeit plant und auch möglicherweise umsetzt, weil er nämlich eine Verwaltungsverfügung erlassen hat. Heute Nacht um die minus zwei Grad, morgen freundlich und trocken bei Temperaturen um die elf Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boerner.
Bei einem palästinensischen Selbstmordanschlag auf ein Hotel in der israelischen Stadt Netanya sind mindestens 15 Menschen getötet worden. 80 Personen wurden zum Teil lebensgefährlich verletzt. Eine klar hat den Gipfel der arabischen Liga in Beirut überschattet. Die palästinensische und die saudiarabische Delegation verließen den Sitzungssaal. Damit reagierten sie auf die Nichtübertragung der Rede von Palästinenser Präsident Arafat aus Ramallah. Zwei Tage nach der Erdbebenkatastrophe in Afghanistan ist die Region heute von starken Nachbeben erschüttert worden. Angaben aus Kabul zufolge gab es dabei erneut Todruhenverletzte. Indessen ist die internationale Hilfe angelaufen. Die Personalräte sowie der Vorstand der angeschlagenen Berliner Bankgesellschaft haben sich auf eine vorläufige Sanierungsvereinbarung geeinigt. Danach sollen die Personalkosten auch um rund 300 Millionen Euro gesenkt werden. Innerhalb der kommenden drei Jahre müssen rund 4.000 Mitarbeiter die Bank verlassen. Der ADAC rechnet für morgen mit dem Beginn der großen Osterreisewelle. Wie im gesamten Bundesgebiet kann es auch am Gründonnerstag auf Brandenburgstraßen zu Staus kommen. Und zum Sport? Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft hat in einem Testländerspiel in Rostock mit 4 zu 2 gegen die Elf aus den USA gewonnen.
Fritz präsentiert den Oster-Sonntag-Feiertag mit der 7-Jahr-Ost-User-Club-Berlin-Party.
Mit dabei Tarnit, Wolle XTP, Tobi Neumann und Anja Schneider im Casino Münstraße 26-30 in Berlin-Hriedersheim.
Und? Und?
Tja, hier ist Chaosradio 70. Wir sprechen über den Zustand des Internets heute Abend, insbesondere über Zensurmaßnahmen, die da möglicherweise angestrengt werden. Derzeit werden sie angestrengt vom Düsseldorfer Regierungspräsidenten. Wie heißt er nochmal, Andi?
Büsso.
Der hat eine Verfügung an nordrhein-westfälische Internetprovider erlassen, dass sie bestimmte Seiten nicht zugänglich mehr machen dürfen. Insbesondere Seiten aus dem Ausland und da Seiten, die sich mit rechtsradikaler Propaganda oder Neonazi-Propaganda beschäftigen bzw. in irgendeiner Form anstößig sind. So was in der Art wie rotten.com.
Damit hat er angefangen. rotten.com hat da jetzt mittlerweile wieder rausgenommen, weil ihm das juristisch nicht zu heikel wurde, weil rotten.com ist nicht mal illegal, sondern ist nur jugendgefährdend. Und jugendgefährdend heißt ja, dass es eben die Jugend gefährdet, aber eben nicht die Erwachsenen. Und da das Internet ja nicht nur von Jugend, sondern auch von Erwachsenen genutzt wird, war ihm das dann wohl juristisch ein bisschen zu öh. Und dann hat er sich also darauf konzentriert, dass was nach seinem Rechtsempfinden oder nach irgendeiner Klassifizierung also eindeutig irgendwie illegal, was weiß ich, ist nach irgendwelchen Gesetzen, die wir hier haben, die zwar aus dem letzten Jahrtausend sind und halt noch aus der Zeit sind, als es um Literatur ging und Bücher und Zeitungen, also nicht um das Internet.
Was bemerkenswert ist, ich kenne diesen Menschen, der rotten.com betreibt und der war irgendwie auch so zu unseren Camps und so in Deutschland und hat dann immer jeweils so mitgebracht, was er noch so an Zensurverfügung von den deutschen Jugendschutzbehörden bekommen hat, die dann auch aufgefordert haben, diese oder jene Subseite von seiner doch irgendwie, sagen wir mal, zumindest irgendwie dem Begriff Meinungsfreiheit, doch etwas strapazierenden Seite aus dem Netz zu nehmen mit irgendwie detaillierten Beschreibungen, warum jetzt irgendwie dieses Foto von irgendeinem aufgeplatzt Motorradfahrer jetzt irgendwie jugendgefährdend und irgendwie Werkhaft zersetzend und sonst irgendwas sei. Und er hatte dann da so Zentimeter dicke Stöße, wo sie jeweils irgendwie einzelne Subindizes mit einer einzigen einzelnen Verfügung belegt haben. Er möge die doch jetzt bitte mal aufleiten, der hat das nicht so richtig verstanden. Die erste hat das sich noch übersetzen lassen, der hat dann auch darüber gelacht.
Eine prima Möglichkeit auch, um irgendwie mal die dämliche deutsche Bürokratie ein bisschen auf Trab zu halten. Sonst haben wir überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun und müssen wieder irgendwelche Halteverbotsschilder aufstellen oder so. Das will man ja auch nicht unbedingt.
Also zumindest irgendwie so die Jugendschutz-Internet-Censor-Bürokratie hat er damit irgendwie einigermaßen effizient beschäftigt.
Die müssen sich das ja den ganzen Tag angucken, ne?
Ja, man kann den ganzen Tag rumdrucken und angucken, müsste aber auch schlechte Laune bekommen.
Ja ey, das wird doch auch mal ein Spaß. Wollen wir denen nicht täglich so 100 Seiten melden, von denen wir glauben, dass sie möglicherweise gegen irgendwas verstoßen?
Ich glaube, der Alvar hatte mir da so eine Geschichte erzählt, dass nämlich genau das teilweise passiert, dass Leute die Bezirksregierung beispielsweise als anstößige Seite gemeldet hat. Und das fanden die dann irgendwie auch nicht mehr komisch. Die haben dann sogar irgendwie mit Gegenmaßnahmen, Gegenanzeigen gedroht. Da gibt es irgendwie so eine merkwürdige Reaktion darauf. Es gibt ja tatsächlich so Seiten, wo man das dann melden kann. Und jene Seite ist irgendwie nach meinem Rechtsempfinden im Plan. In der Art, ja.
Diese Problematik, dass es ein sehr unterschiedliches Verständnis von anstößigen Inhalten gibt, die haben sie jetzt versucht, da rauszunehmen. Weil klar ist, dass die Argumentation relativ einfach ist. Gerade zu sagen, wenn jetzt aber alle arabischen Länder ihre Vorstellung von moralen Anstand im Internet durchsetzen wollen würden, dann wäre das Internet nur noch ein Zehntel so voll. Dann machen wir uns nichts vor. Das Internet wird auf jeden Fall...
Da könnte eh keiner mehr surfen, weil sie allen die Hände abgehackt hätten.
Ja, na zumindest den ganzen MP3 kopieren. Aber ich meine, ich weile das nicht vor. Das Internet wird primär von Porno finanziert. Und dann wäre sozusagen dem Internet die finanzielle Grundlage entzogen, was natürlich ein bisschen nachteilig wäre.
Ja, aber dann wären die Ladezeiten nicht mehr so lang. Wollen wir mal ein bisschen telefonieren?
Ja, da gab es sogar blinkende Lampen.
Da gab es blinkende Lampen. Wir können durchaus mal die Telefonnummer von Blue Moon sagen. Das ist dieselbe wie die Fritz Hotline immer, nämlich die hier.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Ja, jetzt müssten wir euch, liebe Hörende, nur noch eine Frage stellen, damit ihr auch drauf antworten könnt.
Was wir nämlich von euch wissen wollen, ist, was würdet ihr gerne am Internet zensieren?
Ja, was würdet ihr gerne im Internet zensieren? Ruft an, redet mit.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
Guten Abend, Olaf.
Guten Abend.
Und was würdest du denn gerne zensieren?
Ich höre euch ganz schlecht.
Ich sagte, was würdest du denn gerne zensieren?
Was ich gerne zensieren würde? Ja, was ich zensieren würde, sind zum Beispiel, wie ihr schon sagtet, entweder die Neonazi-Seiten oder halt auch diese damals ganz krass Porno-Seiten, die sowieso schon teilweise zensiert sind. Diese Hardware-Seiten? Allgemein?
Na überhaupt, also warum würdest du Nazi-Seiten oder Porno-Seiten zensieren wollen?
Ja, nicht nur Porno und Nazi-Seiten, nur auch satanistische Seiten. Warum? Ja, ganz einfach. Weil ich finde, dass diese Nazi-Seiten die A-Jugend-Gefährden und auch die Erwachsenen-Gefährden sind.
Kannst du das mal genauer ausführen?
Ja, ganz einfach. Ich finde, ich bin auf jeden Fall ein Gegner von Rechtsradikalismus. Und ich finde, dass ich bin wirklich durch die Zufrieden-Seite gelangt. Und finde, dass diese Seiten versuchen, die Leute auch zu werben und auf die Kranze zu agen und weilen.
Ich hab mich ziemlich intensiv mit Insekten beschäftigt. Insekten sind in jedem Fall jugendgefährdend. Und ich würde es als etwas störend empfunden haben, wenn ich mir diese Seiten nicht hätte angucken können, wo ich wertvoll Informationen über diese Leute draus ziehen konnte. Leute, die sich mit Neonazis beschäftigen, denen geht es ganz genauso. Wenn ich meinen Gegner nicht kenne, dann kann ich ihn nicht bekämpfen.
Ja, aber ich meine, ganz ehrlich gesagt, die meisten Gefahr geht von solchen Seiten im Internet aus. Sonst unbedingt so viele Neonazis, denke ich, werden nicht durch einen normalen Gebrauch oder durch normale Treffen von anderen Neonazis unbedingt neu gebunden und werden dann Neonazis.
Also die Stunden des Verfassungsschutzes sagen, dass irgendwie der größte Teil der Neonazis durch neonazistische Musik dazu kommt.
Ja, naja, aber das ist auch im Internet.
Aber lösen wir, Olaf, lösen wir das Problem damit? Ich meine, wenn wir Neonazi-Seiten verbieten, lösen wir doch nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist doch, dass die Menschen, die sich diese Seiten angucken und dadurch agitiert werden, einfach so dumm zu sein scheinen, dass sie auf diesen Wahnsinn reinfallen, der auf diesen Seiten steht. Also müssten wir da nicht viel früher ansetzen, als jetzt anzufangen, irgendwas zu verbieten?
Ja, ist richtig. Aber ich möchte mal ganz kurz dieses Beispiel, was vorhin in den Nachrichten der jungen Mann gesagt hat, die haben doch dieses Experiment gemacht.
Nachzulesen auf www.odem.org.
Genau. Und wo fast keiner gemerkt hat, dass die da die Seiten manipuliert haben. Ich meine, die Leute merken sowas heutzutage kaum noch. Nein, kann man es immer so verabfällen. Man sollte, finde ich.
Ja, aber die Frage, die ich dir dann noch stellen muss, ist also das Problem ist ja, nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe jetzt die Möglichkeit zu zensieren, aber leider wirst du nicht derjenige sein, der die Kriterien ansetzt, sondern das werden irgendwie, vielleicht wird das der Herr Stoiber sein. Ist dir dann wohl bei dem Gedanken, dass der denn definieren kann, was rechtsradikal ist und was nicht? Ich meine, es gibt da Leute, die bezeichnen den als rechtsradikal, und das kann ich teilweise auch nachvollziehen.
Also ganz ehrlich, aber wenn Stoiber die Seiten erstmal mit Stoibernet machen müsste, dann könnte man das ganze Internet abschaffen, denke ich.
Ja, ganz genau, aber die Frage ist genau, wer soll denn die Macht bekommen, das zu tun, wenn du dafür bist?
Ich denke, ganz ehrlich gesagt, finde ich, machen die das vom Jugendschutz ganz gut. Also FSK.
Ja gut, aber die betreffen ja, wir müssen als Zweites einmal unterscheiden. Einmal Inhaltsanbieter, die in Deutschland sind, und die müssen sicher an die deutschen Gesetze halten, das ist unschrittlich. Und da treffen auch die Instanzen sozusagen zu, die du gerade erwähnt hast. Aber die haben normalerweise nichts damit zu tun, was Leute im Ausland tun, wo es andere Gesetze gibt.
Da denke ich schon mal die Sachen, die jetzt in Düsseldorf waren, die Regierung. Da gesagt hat, dass die Provider teilweise Seiten nicht mehr anbieten dürfen, dass sie die einfach sperren müssen, finde ich die Idee gar nicht mal schlecht. Gut, ich halte auch nicht davon, dass nachher krass viele Seiten sperren.
Du hast doch mal wenigstens ausregelt. Olaf, bitte, entschuldige, ich wollte nicht dir ins Wort fallen, sondern...
Also, ich meine, die Schwierigkeit mit dem Sperren von Seiten, von Domainnames, ist doch, dass irgendwie die Nazis auch nicht auf den Kopf gefallen sind. Und wenn sie irgendwie eine Seite bauen wollen, die irgendwie abzurufen ist, dann sind im Zweifel die Zensurjungs immer hinterher. Also es gibt halt irgendwie zwei grundlegende Probleme. Das eine ist, wenn du mit Zensieren anfängst, hast du das Problem, dass irgendjemand die Macht über diese Zensurlisten haben muss. Und diese Macht ist dann mittlerweile schon ganz erheblich, wenn zum Beispiel irgendwie alle Internetprovider verpflichtet sind, diese Seiten zu sperren. Die zweite Problematik ist halt, wenn du Nazis sperren willst, bist du damit nicht effizient. Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Ja, aber ich muss auch ganz ehrlich sagen, wenn ich es jetzt so sehe, wie du siehst, dann sehe ich da keine Hoffnung, was zu sperren. Was ich mir gerade aufgefallen habe, ist nicht böse und nicht gegen dich jetzt allgemein, sondern was ich euch jetzt vorgeschlagen habe, hast du immer abgeplockt. Es ist aber so, wenn man da nicht mal an die Sachen ansetzt, dann kann man es nicht schaffen, ob man das machen muss oder ob man es schafft. Das ist eine ganz andere Sache.
Ich komme aus dem Osten und habe erlebt, was es bedeutet, Realität durch extrem gefilterte Medien wahrzunehmen. Ich bevorzuge es tatsächlich, mein eigenes Bild der Realität zu machen. Wenn es bedeutet, dass ich mir Nazi-Seiten angucken kann, dann heißt es, dass ich mich darüber informieren kann. Für mich ist der Ansatz dabei, nicht zu sagen, ich filtere Realität, weil meine Bevölkerung zu dumm ist, und ich mache die Bevölkerung schlauer.
Ja, man muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es hat nichts damit zu tun, ob du aus dem Osten kommst oder nicht. Denn sagen wir es mal ganz krass so, den Osten gibt es schon ewig nicht mehr, und im Westen auch nicht. Wir sind einiges Berlin, und wir können jetzt schon seit ewiger Zeit die Medien so wahrnehmen, wie sie kommen. Und klar, man wird auch da beeinflusst, aber es ist eine andere Sache. Und ich finde, das kann man jetzt nicht als Ausrede. Das ist für mich nämlich wirklich eine Ausrede.
Ich habe irgendwie 18 Jahre lang keine Zeitungen gehabt, die irgendwie die Realität auch nur anderen widergespiegelt haben. Und ich kann mich da noch sehr gut dran erinnern, wie das war. Und wie gesagt, deswegen möchte ich eigentlich kein Ministerium für Wahrheit haben, was bestimmt irgendwie, was irgendwie ich mir jetzt für Seiten am Internet angucken kann.
Ja, aber wenn ich mal überlege, was ich jetzt schon mitbekomme im Internet teilweise, wo ich auf Seiten weitergeleitet werde, die ich gar nicht haben will.
Dann gehst du halt nicht hin.
Nein, das ist doch gar nicht jetzt, da hast du doch gar nicht den Punkt, das hast du ja nicht verstanden, was ich meine. Du hast mir auch nicht aufreden lassen. Es ist der Punkt, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel auf eine Seite gehe, auf eine Suchmaschinenseite und was eingebe, dann werde ich oftmals mit Bannern bombardiert, oder gleich mit neuen Seiten aufgegeben, die mich dann auf, weiß nicht, ob rechtskalikale Seiten weiter linken oder auf Porno Seiten, die ich gar nicht haben will. Und ich finde, solche Sachen sollte man einschränken.
Dann schaltest du JavaScript in deinem Browser aus, dann bist du das Problem los.
Also der Unterschied ist doch, du kannst dir ja zu Hause bei dir gerne einen Filter hinstellen. Also ich mach das auch so, wenn ich die Werbung nicht sehen will, nehme ich einen Proxy, der die Werbung für mich rausfiltert. Ist doch kein Ding, wenn du keine Lust auf Pornos und Rechtsradikalismus in deinem Browser hat, dann stell das bitte in deinem Browser ein. Aber wieso willst du das für mich mitentscheiden?
Ich rede ja auch eigentlich jetzt von mir, eher von mir gesagt. Allgemein muss ich von ganz ehrlich so sagen, ich finde es auch immer schwarz, wenn Leute sagen, sie reden in der Wirrform. Ich meine, ich kann nicht entscheiden, was sie wollen. Ich kann nicht entscheiden, was meine Freunde wollen. Ich kann nur entscheiden, was ich will. Und ich würde für mich halt sagen, wenn ich jetzt das bestimmen würde, ich würde sagen, das und das würde ich machen. Ich meine, ich kann nicht sagen in der Wirrform, weil ich stoße so und so auf Gegenmeinungen.
Würdest du denn, wenn du sagst, du möchtest bestimmte Dinge nicht sehen, würdest du denn wirklich dein Schicksal in fremde Hände übergeben wollen, sodass jemand anders bestimmen darf, was du nicht sehen willst?
Dann darf man ja wieder nur sagen, was man nicht sehen darf. Aber na ja, ich denke immer, es gibt gewisse Punkte, wo ich sage ja, und es gibt gewisse Punkte, wo ich sage nein.
Also Cookies und JavaScript ausschalten wir auf jeden Fall als Selbsthilfemaßnahmen. Ich meine, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich um das geht, was du nicht sehen willst, dann ist es ja auch eine Frage, inwieweit du sozusagen verhinderst, dass Leute dir Webseiten in deinem Browser aufrufen, die du nicht willst. Und das ist halt im Teil des Tages einfache technische Maßnahmen.
Nee, aber ich hab's auch schon miterlebt, dass eine Seite verboten wurde, wo ich vorher immer drauf war, da war wirklich ein Grund, dass ich fast gar nicht amstlöslich war.
Welche war das?
Kann ich dir jetzt nicht mehr sagen, genau. Das war eine komplizierte Adi. Und da waren glaube ich nur drei, vier Bilder drauf, die wirklich amstlöslich waren. Also wirklich wendlich harmloser als rotten.com. Und die haben sie gesperrt. Und ich finde Sachen wie rotten.com, da gibt's eine Menge Widersprüche, aber die finde ich ehrlich gesagt pervers. Weil da Sachen abgebildet werden und deswegen bin ich da auch gar nicht drauf. Ich hab die nur einmal gesehen und die fand ich einfach pervers. Und ich finde Leute leiden, Leute gesperrt werden.
Ja, findest du es denn besser, wenn über Kriegsberichterstattungen beispielsweise, wenn da eben keine Bilder von Toten gezeigt werden, obwohl da Leute sterben?
Das ist aber was anderes, denke ich.
Nee, das ist nicht was anderes, sondern teilweise zeigt rotten.com ja authentische Bilder, teilweise auch gefakte Bilder.
Ja, aber...
Und die zeigen halt genau die Bilder, die du in den normalen Medien nicht kriegst. Obwohl halt Leute sterben im Rahmen von Aktionen, die wir hier mitlegitimieren.
Nein, jein. Aber ich denke, wenn du jetzt einfach mal eine Leise hast, die über den ganzen Krieg, wenn man gerade beim Krieg löhnt, wenn man den ganzen Krieg mal widerspiegelt, dann wirst du auch Lachen finden von Toten. Hundertprozentig sogar. Die werden vielleicht nicht so krass sein wie bei rotten.com, aber du wirst auch Fotos finden von Toten. Und das meine ich nämlich. Man kann ja alles zeigen, aber man kann auch das so zeigen, dass das nicht wirklich pervers wird. Und ich finde rotten.com geht da ziemlich, ziemlich weit.
Na gut, aber du musst diese Seite ja nicht aufrufen.
Ist richtig, aber davon ist doch nicht nur Diesel. Es gibt auch viele andere Seiten, garantiert noch im Netz. Ich kenne jetzt momentan wirklich nur Diesel, deswegen kann ich keine andere Art nennen.
Olaf, wo würdest du die Grenze ziehen? Für wen würdest du die Zensur, die Form der Zensur oder das Ausmaß an Zensur, was du forderst, für wen würdest du das fordern? Würdest du sagen, wer über 18 ist, der darf dann wieder?
Ja, weil ich bin mal ganz ehrlich der Meinung. Ich bin ja selber erst 17, also dadurch ist es eine Sache, da kann ich nicht einfach sagen, ich bin schon über 18 oder so, sondern das würde mich auch einschränken. Und ich bin einfach dafür, weil ich einfach mal denke, vor allem die Jugendlichen unter 15 und unter 16, die haben teilweise echt noch, wo ich sage, na die können vielleicht noch nicht ganz unter Realität und Wahrheit unterscheiden. Was jetzt natürlich eine harte Aussage ist, das gebe ich zu.
Naja, nee, ich meine, wir wissen doch alle, mit 13, 14 oder wie auch immer hast du ja tatsächlich Probleme. Also würdest du eher sagen, so eine Art Jugendschutzzensur?
Ja, und ich meine, damit haben sie doch schon teilweise begonnen, das finde ich ja auch gut. Und deswegen, ich meine, ich würde das jetzt nicht für Erwachsener unbedingt verbieten, ich würde auch vielleicht neonatliche Seiten auch nicht für Erwachsene verbieten oder satanistische Seiten. Ich meine, das müssen die Leute selber entscheiden, ob sie raufgehen. Aber Jugendliche, ich meine, vor allem latanistische Seiten momentan, finde ich, sollten ganz krass unter diese JFK kommen. Weil wenn man momentan mal sieht, was da wieder an Sachen passiert, nur wegen dem Satan glauben, ich meine, da, finde ich, müssten sie ganz schnell reagieren und müssten ganz schnell mal so eine Jugendschutz-Sachen einbauen. Das ist für mich mal ne Sache, weil ich denke, die Jugendlichen sind da stärker gefährdet als die Erwachsenen. Weil sag mal so, ich sag den Erwachsenen einfach mal so aus, die haben Trips, die haben Lebenserfahrung, sie müssen was im Geist haben.
Alles klar. Olaf, danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, kein Problem.
Hier die Nummer.
0331 für Potsdam, 7097110.
In der Musik haben wir eben ganz viel gehört, jetzt telefonieren wir mit Hörern, das ist nämlich Talkradio. Das ist übrigens der Blumenau, Fritz, das Chaosradio, 70. Wir reden über Zensur, denn das Internet soll jetzt langsam aber sicher zensiert werden. Nordrhein-Westfalen fängt damit an. Der Regierungspräsident hat, wie hieß das, Andi?
Eine Sperrversicherung.
Eine Sperrversicherung an die Provider rausgeschickt. Wir haben noch einen, der für Zensur ist. Hallo, Reinhard.
Was Herr Beuer gesagt hat, fand ich schon in Ordnung, aber es war mir zu blöd, weil Zensur kam... Ich finde es nur in der Hinsicht gut, dass Medien-Sachen nicht so doll an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, dass so viele Leute nicht so viel mitkriegen, was wirklich in der Welt passiert, auch wenn es ihr Recht ist. Aber wenn man Tote oder irgendwelche Sachen, wie ihr meint, was passiert bei irgendwelchen Einsätzen, sagen wir mal jetzt wieder in Afghanistan, im Internet zeigt, wie es wirklich passiert ist, schafft man auch bloß wieder Gewalt, oder?
Oder du schaffst dein Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung, vielleicht solche Kriege nicht zu legitimieren. Das ist natürlich die andere Seite.
Wenn du überlegst, dass der Krieg in Vietnam dadurch beendet wurde, dass die Leute durch die Medienberichte keine Lust mehr darauf hatten, möchte ich schon gerne einigermaßen vollständig informiert werden. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die Amerikaner umsonst so eine dermaßen tief geöffnete Medienzenso betreiben.
Aber ja, ihr habt beide Recht. Das ist schon in Ordnung. Aber ich meine es ja nur in der Gewissheit, dass man diese bestialischen Sachen nicht so zeigt. Weil, auch wenn das natürlich diese Leute...
Ja, aber wenn Krieg immer bestialische Dinge anrichtet, warum soll man die denn nicht zeigen? Willst du dann sagen, das ist alles ganz schön?
Naja, aber die Allgemeinheit, die Bevölkerung wird da unruhig.
Ja, ganz genau, ganz genau.
Das ist eher ein Problem.
Aber wenn die unruhig sind, sind sie nicht mehr glücklich. Und da ist keine Harmonie mehr.
Oh ja, lass uns die Zensur einfügen, damit die Bevölkerung glücklich ist.
Nein, das kannst du nicht so sagen.
Na ja, das hast du gerade so gesagt.
Ja, hast du falsch verstanden.
Na gut, also ich meine, eigentlich stellt sich dort die Frage, wer hat denn das Recht, tatsächlich die Realitätswahrnehmung der Bevölkerung zu manipulieren? Also wer ist tatsächlich irgendwie dazu befugt? Mir fällt da spontan niemand ein.
Ja, wieso wird einer gefunden werden? Und da wird ein Gremium geben und ich würde nicht einer alleine entscheiden.
Das Ministerium für Wahrheit? Naja, also, so richtig tolle Argumente hast du ja auch nicht gehört.
Ja, da hast du ja auch recht, irgendwo zerredest du mich hier.
Entschuldigung.
Nee, ist ok, eigentlich hast du ja recht. Das Schlimme ist ja, dass ich eigentlich dafür bin, aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise muss ich dazu sagen, eigentlich lasst doch die Leute den ganzen Scheiß reden, wa?
Ja, was wir eben hatten, also die Lösung für das Problem... Die Lösung ist eigentlich nur Konfrontation damit. Die Lösung für das Problem ist, dass wir es vielleicht mal schaffen, die Bevölkerung von der Bild- und der Bizette wegzubringen und vielleicht hin zur Süddeutschen Zeitung oder zur Zeit, denn der Kampf gegen die Dummheit hat gerade erst begonnen, damit werben die ja auch mit dem Spruch. Also vielleicht ist die Lösung, die Bevölkerung ein bisschen schlauer zu machen, weil nur die Blöden fallen auf die blöden Seiten rein. Entschuldigung. Ja, mach ich doch. Reinhard, da musst du jetzt sagen, danke für meinen Anruf.
Ja, ich danke dir für meinen Anruf.
Gute Nacht, tschüss.
0331 77 91 10 ist die Nummer, wenn ihr hier im Chaosradio mitreden wollt. Wollt wir reden über Zensur und darüber reden wir mit Stefan. Hallo Stefan.
Ja, ich bin eigentlich gegen Zensur, weil ich finde es Schwachsinn. Ich habe aber überhaupt keine Ahnung von Internet und bin da noch nie drin gewesen, weil mich das nervt mit den ganzen Werbung und so. Und man erst eine halbe Stunde runden doktoren muss, bis man überhaupt mal zum Pottekommt. Also davon habe ich eigentlich keine Ahnung. Ich rede nur über das Prinzip, dass es eigentlich nur springt, wenn man von irgendjemanden jetzt eine Zensur oder irgendwas, was angeblich scheiße wäre, zensiert und das dann nicht mehr bringt. Es ist Schwachsinn, weil jeder müsste sich eigentlich seine Meinung selber bilden können.
Okay, aber wie hindern wir die braunen Horden daran, ihre Propaganda zu verbreiten? Weil das wollen wir ja nicht, dass sie das tun.
Wir können sie nicht daran hindern. Im Internet jedenfalls ist es schlecht. Und ich meine, sollen sie ruhig, sollen sie ruhig machen. Die Leute können doch irgendwann mal, die werden es doch irgendwann begreifen, dass das irgendwie Schwachsinn ist. Es gibt auch viele andere Möglichkeiten, sich noch über den Zweiten Weltkrieg zu informieren. Allerdings, was ich denen zugute halten muss, sie informieren darüber ziemlich, naja wie ich das mal höre, darüber wird ziemlich hintergründlich berichtet. Und es gibt irgendwie scheinbar keine anderen Seiten, die Jugendliche auch ansprechen, die auch Geschichte aufarbeiten.
Na doch, es gibt ja zum Beispiel so Geschichten, dass jüdische Organisationen teilweise eben versuchen, genau dieselben Stichworte, die Nazis auch besetzen, also was heißt, ich Ausschwitzlüge und so weiter, sofort eben auch zu besetzen. Damit, wenn du suchmaschinenmäßig nach diesem Kram suchst, du eben nicht nur Dreckinformation der Nazis, findest du eben auch einfach Darstellungen von Leuten, die da waren und die da betroffene Opfer waren und so fort. Also das ist ja auch eine der Strategien, die da so im Raum stehen.
Na ja, das klingt jetzt vielleicht auch blöd, aber es ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel von Juden heutzutage zu hören. Was ist mit den ganzen Polen und den ganzen Kommunisten, mit den ganzen Russen, die vergast wurden?
Ja gut, ich meine von den Palästinern könnten halt auch reden.
Was ist mit den Juden eigentlich, die jetzt dort mit ihrem Land die Scheiße bauen?
Das sind in erster Linie Israelis, das sind erst in zweiter Linie Juden.
Muss man auch sehen.
Ich hab einige jüdische Freunde, die würde ich nie dafür verantwortlich machen, was die israelische Regierung dafür einen Massaker anrichtet.
Ja, ich weiß ja auch, dass es vernünftige Juden gibt, nur leider verliert man manchmal den Glauben an das Gute, wenn man nur diese Idioten sieht.
Die haben wir nun in unserem Kulturkreis ja auch gut verteilt.
Das ist eigentlich auch so ein typisches Phänomen der deutschen Gesellschaft, dass Kritik an Israel dann auch immer gleich als Antisemitismus einfach verunlimpft wird. Dass halt natürlich eine Menge Leute frustriert werden, weil sie halt einfach bestimmte Meinungen nicht mehr äußern können und eigentlich nicht wirklich antisemitisch eingestellt sind.
Ja, genau. Irgendwie wird das was mich extrem stört, dass man gleich als Antisemit dasteht, wenn man was gegen Israel sagt.
Nee, wenn du was gegen Israel sagst, da hab ich überhaupt kein Problem mit. Wenn du was gegen Juden sagst, da hab ich ein riesen Problem mit. Weil Israel wird zwar hauptsächlich von Menschen jüdischen Glaubensbevölkern. Die Juden verstehen sich sogar als Ethnie und nicht nur als Religionsgemeinschaft. Aber nichtsdestotrotz sind es in erster Linie die Israelis. Also da hab ich einfach wirklich arge Probleme mit der Wortwahl. Solange hier jüdische Friedhöfe geschändet werden, solange hier Menschen von irgendwelchen idiotischen Rechtsradikalen verdroschen und umgebracht werden, finde ich, kann man es nicht lockerer sehen. Also wirklich, wenn Sharon vorbeikommt und irgendjemand haut Sharon eins auf die Schnauze, dann applaudiere ich ihm und gebe ihm ein Bienchen. Aber wenn er nur irgendeinem Juden aufs Maul haut, nur weil er Jude ist, dann hat er noch lange kein Bienchen verdient.
Nee, aber ich bin irgendwie, mich nervt es einfach, dass man alles überlegen muss, was man sagt, dass das ja auch politisch korrekt ist. Das ist extrem anstrengend für mich. Dann kann man niemals irgendwie über gewisse Sachen einfach offen reden.
Aber gut, dass wir Deutschen da auch eine gewisse Verantwortung haben, uns differenziert auszudrücken, weil wir Kritik an Israel äußern, dass wir dann auch irgendwie sagen, an wem wir da Kritik haben und nicht nur, ich glaube, man muss da ein bisschen Verständnis haben. Ich meine, political correctness ist im Zweifelsfall auch die Übertreibung davon, wenn du nämlich in der Tat gar nichts mehr sagen kannst, weil im Zweifelsfall eben alles nicht korrekt ist, weil es im Zweifelsfall eben auch nicht korrekt ist, Herrn Charon auf die Fresse zu hauen, politisch gesehen, sondern politisch korrekt gesehen, müsste man mit ihm Hirse-Tee trinken und mit ihm mal über die Gewaltfrage diskutieren. Ob das aber den Ziel führt, ist irgendwie eine andere Frage.
Entschuldigung, wir müssen da mal drüber reden.
Herr 70-jähriger Greiser General.
Aber nützt eben nur stark Kerzen anzuzünden, dann können wir den Krieg da nicht enden.
Ja, ich meine, mit dieser politischen Korrekter, da stimme ich dir ja zu, dass das irgendwie auch nicht unbedingt zielführend ist, aber ein bisschen differenzieren schadet, glaube ich, nicht im Sprachgebrauch. Dann landet man da schnell eben bei so Klischee-Geschichten und ist sich dann selber auf einmal Klischee-Vorwürfen ausgesetzt. Und wenn du als Deutscher im Ausland unterwegs bist, dann erlebst du da manchmal auch sehr merkwürdige Dinge, wo du denkst, also Entschuldigung mal, das ist irgendwie die Generation vor meinen Eltern gewesen und ob ich damit jetzt wirklich nicht noch assoziieren will.
Ich war mal in Ukraine und habe mir Sachen gehört, dass die Slaven mit der deutschen Rasse verbunden sind und so was.
Allein das Wort Rasse ist ja schon eine Idiotie an sich.
Ja, und ich versuchte das Gespräch zu beenden, war aber nicht mehr so einfach.
Es ist relativ schwierig jemandem klarzumachen, dass es sowas wie Rasse nicht gibt unter Menschen, aber sie lesen eben doch alle die BZ. Stefan, ich danke an dieser Stelle für deinen Anruf.
Ja, ich danke euch, dass ihr diese Sendung macht.
Wir tun unser Bestes. Alles klar, eine gute Nacht noch, tschüss. Ja. 70 ist hier um 04. Wir wollen jetzt zu reden und reden wollen wir über den derzeitigen Zustand des Internets. Der wird sich nämlich langsam aber sich erändern. Vor allen Dingen in Nordrhein-Westfalen, da fängt er gerade an sich zu ändern, der nordrhein-westfälische Ministerpräsident, Regierungspräsident, nein, der Düsseldorfer Regierungspräsident, jetzt hab ich's. Ich spule mal eben zurück.
Der Regierungspräsident der Düsseldorfer Bezirksregierung, Herr Büssow.
Ja, der Regierungspräsident in Düsseldorf, Herr Büssow hat eine Sperrverfügung an Internetprovider rausgeschickt und da steht drin, hier bestimmte ausländische Seiten nicht mehr darstellen. Da handelt es sich um rechtsradikale Sachen, da handelt es sich um anstößige oder jugendgefährdende Sachen. Damit kann man einverstanden sein, kann man aber auch nicht. Wenn ihr einverstanden seid, dann ruft hier an unter 0331 und wenn ihr nicht einverstanden seid damit, dann ruft bitte diese Nummer hier an. 0331 Potsdam 70 97 110 Also in jedem Fall ruft diese Nummer an, denn das ist der Blumen auf Fritz und der Blumen ist eine Hörer Talk Sendung, auch wenn er Chaosradio heißt. Hallo Dieter. Hey krass, ich kann mit mir selber reden, pass mal auf. Ist ja klasse, warte mal, seid mal alle leise jetzt. Hallo Holger, wie geht's denn so?
Hallo, da spricht sie.
Das ist ja köstlich. Dieter, entschuldige mal, du hörst uns über das Netz, oder? Dieter?
Ja?
Du hörst uns über das Internet, oder? Das ist sehr klasse, weil das kommt mit so einer, ja, wieviel Sekunden? Zehn Sekunden Verzögerung oder noch ein Lachlänger? Bei dir an und das führt dazu, dass ich mich mit mir selber unterhalten kann. Das finde ich total klasse.
Also es gibt andere Leute, die wollen sich auch unterhalten mit euch.
Ja, aber ich will erst mal mit mir selber. Na gut, Dieter, weil du's bist. Schieß los. Zensur im Netz.
Okay Leute, also Zensur taugt nix.
Warum nicht?
Das ist ganz einfach, weil wenn ich irgendwas haben will, ich hol's mir. Wenn nicht in Deutschland, dann von irgendwo. Also das bringt gar nix. Sprich, das geht mit den Spielen los. In Deutschland natürlich spielt man ein gutes Game. Woanders da blutet es. In Deutschland blutet es gar nicht. Also krieg ich es in Deutschland nicht. Hol ich es mir per Internet oder fahr in Urlaub, nimm es hier mit. Bringt gar nix.
Das heißt, du gehst gar nicht jetzt von der moralischen Seite, also ethisch-moralischen Seite aus und sagst, so bringt nix, sondern du sagst, es nutzt sowieso nichts, weil sie ohnehin umgangen werden wird, egal wie sie aussieht.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Es gibt Sachen, wo ich nicht dafür bin. Also das ist schon richtig. Nur ob das mit Zensur damit bereinigt ist, also ich glaub's nicht.
Wobei es in der DDR ja weitestgehend funktioniert hat.
Bitte?
Gab's auch Westfernsehen.
Ja, aber nur wenn deine Eltern nicht bei der Stasi waren und das waren ja die meisten. Ja Dieter, Entschuldige, weiter.
Ja, wie die beiden Vorsprecher vorher, also mit Rottenkomm. Ich meine, die Bilder, wo man auf Rottenkomm sieht, sind zum Großteil Realität und warum soll man die Realität nicht sehen?
Naja, weil ich vielleicht einen 14-jährigen Sohn habe, der in seiner emotionalen Entwicklung noch nicht so weit ist, dass er das ertragen kann, diese Bilder zu sehen, der darüber vielleicht krank wird.
Naja, ich meine, da ist schon was dran, nur wie kann man verhindern, auch über Filter, dass das nicht funktioniert wie bei uns in der Arbeit. Also wir haben Internet, wird natürlich nicht gern gesehen, wenn das für private Zwecke genutzt werden, sind natürlich auch Filter eingebaut. Die funktionieren auch, würde aber nur sagen, zu 60, 70 Prozent, weil komme ich hier über diese Seite nicht rein.
Was wird da gefiltert? Was wird da so gefiltert bei dir auf der Arbeit? Was wird bei dir auf der Arbeit so gefiltert?
Aus der Arbeit zugeschildert?
Na, ich will wissen, was bei dir auf der Arbeit gefiltert wird. Dieter? Du kannst mich schon verstehen, oder? Ja nun gut, was wird denn bei dir auf der Arbeit so gefiltert?
Also der Arbeit ist nur für dienstliche Sachen geeignet und private Sachen haben überhaupt nichts zum suchen. Und Sexseiten sind so und so gesperrt und bla bla bla bla hier und bla bla dort. Nur wenn man gucken will, dann geht man halt nicht von der Vordertür rein, sondern von der Hintertür.
Und was sagt denn der Arbeitgeber dazu?
Tja, der Arbeitgeber sagt noch was dazu, wenn einem draufkommt.
Das heißt, der guckt sich noch nicht mehr die Filterlocks an?
Ja, doch, guckt an.
Und dann, was passiert dann?
Eine Abmahnung.
In jedem Fall eine Abmahnung.
Ja.
Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon eine große Anzahl von Produkten, die dann halt für nur 10.000 Euro für drei Jahre irgendwie einen Prima-Filter mit Logging verkaufen.
Nee, da hat der Bezirk Niederbayern ihren Geld dazu.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Da ist ein technisch Überwachungs-Trainer angestellt und der guckt da. Und wenn es einer zu übertreibt, dann gibt es einen hier auf dem Deckel.
Hattet ihr nicht auch noch irgendwie so einen Abgeordneten, der irgendwie mit 190er-Nummern seinen Spaß hatte?
Ah, gleich. Schöne Grüße an Herrn Wallner. Der wird wahrscheinlich gerade wieder telefonieren.
Bevor das hier überhängt, nimm Dieter. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Circa 15 Kilometer, ne 10 Kilometer Langweg zum Herrn Wallner.
Dann fahr doch mal hin und bestell ihm schöne Grüße.
Also nochmal gesagt zur Zensur, wer soll mir vorschreiben, was ich angucken will oder angucken kann oder nicht.
Naja und wie du selber schon sagtest, wenn es dir einer vorschreibt, kannst du sowieso umgehen.
Eben.
Alles klar, ich danke für deinen Anruf.
Manche Seiten anschaut und man ist irgendwie noch ein bisschen gesund im Kopf. Dann stellt man so und so fest, dass das scheiße ist. Und dann schaut man sich die Seiten so und so nicht mehr an.
Alles klar, Dieter, machs gut.
Habt ihr eine Pürdeich.
Pürdeich.
So und dann hätten wir noch Marianne in der Leitung. Hallo Marianne. Ja, du bist jetzt feit dran.
Ja, ich bin dran. Und zwar, ich mein das eigentlich genauso wie der Dieter, aber wenn man das unbedingt will, wenn man unbedingt da ran kommen will an die Bilder oder was weiß ich an was, dann kriegt man das von irgendeinem Freund oder versucht das irgendwie an das Zeug ran zu kommen und irgendwie so eine Zensierung hätte irgendwie keinen Sinn. Weil irgend einer denkt sich wieder irgendwas aus, um irgendwie wieder vorbeizukommen und nach einer halben Stunde ist das erledigt.
Ist das denn nicht grässlich? Du sagst Zensur ist eben blöd oder böse oder was auch immer. Nein, du sagst ja eigentlich Zensur hat keinen Sinn.
Es ist nicht blöd, aber es ist halt irgendwie zwecklos.
Das heißt, du würdest Zensur befürworten, wenn es eine technische Möglichkeit gäbe, diese Zensur tatsächlich lückenlos durchzuführen?
Ja, dann wäre es auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Nur, ich würde es halt für die Leute, die unter 18 sind, verbieten.
Warum wäre das eine gute Sache?
Das geht ja dann schon wieder nie, wenn man das dann wieder einrichten würde.
Warum wäre das eine gute Sache? Oder andersherum gefragt, was würdest du mir verbieten, zu sehen?
Na, verbieten könnte ich dir nichts, weil du ja erwachsen bist.
Achso, auch du würdest sagen, Zensur tatsächlich nur bei Minderjährigen? Ich weiß nicht, offensichtlich ist unser tolles neues Studio nicht in der Lage. Kannst du uns jetzt besser verstehen? Jetzt geht's besser?
Der hat gerade geredet.
Holger, du musst näher ans Mikrofon.
Geh mal ins Mikrofon rein.
Dann machst du noch den Mund auf beim Reden, dann funktioniert das auch.
Hier gibt es ein tolles neues digitales Studio, das mit Windows NT läuft. Bis jetzt ist es noch nicht abgestürzt, solange wir hier drin waren. Du hast zwei Stunden.
Das ist schnell geboten, wir haben es nicht gesehen.
Schönes.
Marianne, du meinst, wenn Zensur dann tatsächlich auch wieder nur für Minderjährige?
Nur, weil ab 18 ist man ja heutzutage in Deutschland eigentlich erwachsen. Da darf man ja fast alles.
Aber würde es denn da nicht reichen, wenn beispielsweise du bist 16, deine Eltern diese Zensurmaßnahme durchführen? Also muss dann da wieder der Staat oder die Regierung einschreiten?
Ja, weil die Eltern, ich will in Rummeckern, aber wie wollen die Eltern das denn überwachen? Wenn die Eltern das machen, dann wird es fast nur blöd sein. Also das hätte doch weniger Sinn, wenn es die Eltern irgendwie überwachen sollten. Ja, was machst du denn, was machst du denn? Die haben da ohnehin einen ganzen Kopf fest.
Und umgekehrt, wenn man für die Eltern das netzen sehen würde?
Das würde ja auch nicht gehen, weil die ja dann erwachsen sind. Das geht ja nicht. Das hätte ja dann keinen Sinn. Da könnte ich ja alles sehen, meine Eltern nicht.
Ja klar, ich meine, in der technischen Realität ist es ja oft so, dass eher die Jugendlichen, diejenigen sind, die so ein bisschen mit der Technik besser klarkommen als die Eltern. Ich meine, es kommt immer drauf an auf den Haushalt, aber ist ja doch oft so.
Ja, in der Regel bei mir ist es auch so.
Kannst du denn deinen Eltern das ganze Internet zumuten?
Ja, also das, was die machen, also meine Mutter macht gar nichts, meine Frau, naja, weiß nicht, ich irgendwelche Banküberweisungen, mehr macht der Uni, ich würde sagen, na versteht der Uni.
Also das Interessante ist immer, wenn dann, ich hatte zum Beispiel mal, da kam irgendwann mal so eine Berliner Hausfrau mit ihrer Göre zu mir und da ging es darum, dass sie irgendwie eine Telefonrechnung in wirklich beachtlicher Höhe hatten, durch so ein Dialer, also durch so ein Programm, was halt auf den PC installiert war und dann den Internetzugang über die 990er nochmal gehalten war.
Ja, das hatten wir irgendwie, oh, ich weiß ungedurch, was das war, aber da hatten wir plötzlich, das war wenig, aber trotzdem.
Ja, das Interessante ist, dass bei solchen Gelegenheiten dann immer rauskommt, wer dann mit dem PC eigentlich was macht im Haushalt und wer sich welche Seiten anguckt. Und manchmal ist das wirklich erstaunlich.
Ja, ich würde mal sagen, die merken das ja irgendwie, weil sie ja irgendwie, na, weiß ja halt nicht so richtig viel Schaltwissen darüber, und da merken die das, was die jetzt genau machen. Also wenn ich das jetzt sehen würde, dann würde ich so, also bestimmt nach fünf Minuten maximal sehen, dass es schon soweit ist. Ich würde sie vielleicht gar nicht erst soweit kommen lassen. Also dann schreib ich eigentlich schon nicht. Und apropos, wegen dem, dass sie dort herankommen, von einem Freund von mir, möchte ich gleich grüßen, Sven, den seine Mutter arbeitet irgendwie in der JVA, in Zeithalm, und die Leute dort, die dort einsetzen, die kommen dort, die bauen sich dort aus Radios, bauen die sich irgendwelche Tätowiermaschinen, also die machen dort alles mögliche, die, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen, und na, sieht auch noch gut aus, die hatten irgendwie einen Film oder gebracht, vor dem er irgendwann mal, jedenfalls, die kommen wo ran, und ich weiß nicht, es hätte einfach keinen Sinn, weil es fast nebendurch ist dann.
Okay, Marian, danke für deinen Anruf und gute Nacht noch.
Ich wollte Ihnen noch was sagen. Ach so? Wegen dem Internet. Weil unsere Rechnung ja immer so hoch ist, und zwar wollte ich jetzt mal ein bisschen Werbung machen, weil wir da noch viele Leute brauchen.
Werbung, nee, also Werbung ist ja wirklich überhaupt nicht unbedingt das Ding. Werbung ist ja irgendwie so gar nicht das Ding, was wir jetzt machen dürfen und auch eigentlich gar nicht, was wir jetzt machen wollen, Marianne. Das tut mir sehr leid. Eine gute Nacht noch. Ja, Chaosradio 70, haben wir noch ein bisschen Musik.
Ja, wir haben das Lied von der unruhvollen Jugend.
Das Lied von der Unruh, wie schön.
Hier ist Chaosradio Nummer 70. Eigentlich wollten wir über Zensur reden, aber wir haben uns gerade von diesem Thema verabschiedet. Andi Müller-Margun hat einen unglaublich guten Vorschlag gerade gemacht. Kann ich ihn nochmal hören?
Naja, wir haben uns halt überlegt, dass die Antworten und die Anrufe, die kommen auf die Frage, die haben sich halt so eingeschossen. Wir sind jetzt gegen Zensur und deswegen dachten wir, können wir ja jetzt mal die nächsten Probleme lösen sozusagen. Und eine der dringendsten Fragestellungen wäre dann doch jetzt, wie wir jetzt irgendwie die Regierung stürzen oder mal konstruktive Dinge initiieren.
Ja, liebe Hörfunkfreunde, wie können wir in den verbleibenden 30 Minuten noch die Regierung stürzen oder konstruktive Dinge vollbringen? Bitte teilt es uns mit, wir wissen es nicht.
0331 für Potsdam, 70, 97, 110.
All die Jahre hab ich mich gefragt, warum heißt diese Veranstaltung eigentlich Chaosradio? Jetzt weiß ich's. Wir nehmen einfach mal, also pass auf, jetzt machen wir die Verwirrung komplett.
Ist noch Musik da drunter?
Wir nehmen Benny ran. Benny, wir haben gerade das Thema gewechselt, möchtest du trotzdem mit uns sprechen? Hallo, Benny? Hallo?
Ich glaube, wir haben nur so ein Akustikproblem, oder?
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Kannst du uns hören, Benny?
Leicht im Hintergrund.
Leicht im Hintergrund, besser vielleicht?
Ja, die Stimme eben, ja, die hab ich relativ gut gehört.
Ich glaube, du hast was mit deinem Mikro.
Ja, aber was hab ich denn mit meinem Mikro?
Bist du vielleicht gegen den Regler gekommen?
Ich bin nicht gegen den Regler gekommen. Warum kann mich ja keiner hören?
Vielleicht liegt der Laptop auf der Rolls-Royce-Battaste?
Ja, nee, dann sprecht ihr mal mit Benny.
Benny kann mich ja sowieso nicht hören. Ich weiß nicht, du weißt, was jetzt die Frage ist?
Wie kann man die Regierung stürzen?
Ja, naja, das war jetzt nur so ein bisschen, weil wir haben uns überlegt, wir kommen gerade nicht so richtig voran. Also wir sagen, die Antworten sind alles schön, aber irgendwie hatten wir schon fast den Eindruck, das Thema sei erschöpft oder ist es das noch nicht?
Also meiner Meinung nach nicht.
Ne, weil? Okay.
Weil man kann ja mal überlegen, wenn Zensur, wie groß müssten denn die Ausmaße sein?
Du meinst, wenn wir jetzt konstruktiv damit anfangen und bei der Gelegenheit noch andere Dinge zensieren, zum Beispiel die ganze Werbung mal wegzensieren, oder wie?
Ähm, mehr oder weniger. Also ich mein jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn man etwas zensiert, wie macht man das denn? Macht man das in einer Stadt zum Beispiel oder in einem Land oder auf der ganzen Welt? Und wie kann man das auf der ganzen Welt kontrollieren? Weil das Netz ist ziemlich groß und ja, das zu kontrollieren ist fast unmöglich, würde ich sagen.
Also das würde ich nicht sagen. Da könnte ich ja zusammen wieder auf das erste Thema zurückkommen, nämlich auf ICAN. ICAN ist ja ein bisschen im gewissen Sinne der Versuch globale Kontrolle zumindest über alle Namensraumbetreiber zu erwirken. Also alle über diejenigen, die sie sogenannten Registries im DNS betreiben. Das sind also die Top-Level-Domain-Datenbanken sowohl eben der Länder als auch der generischen. Und hier gibt es ja in der Tat im Moment sozusagen, deswegen haben wir ja diese uneinheitliche Situation, weil wir nun mal unterschiedliche Jurisdiktionen, wir sagen Rechtsräume haben, in Amerika sind bestachene Nummer bestimmte Sachen erlaubt, die hier verboten sind und so fort. Und das versucht Aiken ja aber, ob das halt irgendwie in irgendeiner Form wünschenswert ist, sozusagen, dass die Spielregeln auf diesem Planeten weltweit einheitlich sind. Das ist erstmal eine Frage, würde ich sagen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Weil du meintest, man müsste das global machen oder so.
Ja, schon, aber der Name sagt ja auch nicht viel über den Inhalt der Seite aus. Weil man kann sich jetzt zum Beispiel Kirschmarmelade nennen und dann irgendwas über, weiß ich, die rechte Szene oder so machen.
Ja klar, aber es gibt ja Fälle, wie zum Beispiel, es gab so eine österreichische Künstlergruppe, die zu den Zeiten, als dieser amerikanische Wahlkampf lief oder vielmehr die Wahl des amerikanischen Präsidenten in dieser absurden Situation landete, dass irgendwie keiner jetzt genau wusste, wer jetzt gewählt wurde. Und dann gab es ja noch die zu erwartenden Stimmen aus den Briefwahlvorgängen. Und die haben in Österreich so einen Server aufgesetzt und dann sich die Domain voteaction.com geholt. Und sich hat also überlegt, das ist zwar jetzt alles schon ganz schön absurd, aber noch nicht absurd genug. Und wir versteigern jetzt einfach sozusagen, wir bieten jetzt amerikanischen Bürgern, die auch über Briefwahl wählen können, die Möglichkeit, ihre Stimme meist bieten zu versteigern. Was dann halt passiert ist, ist, ein Gericht in Minnesota fand das irgendwie nicht so komisch wie diese Leute in Wien und hat den Domain-Namen mit einer so einer Art einsfeiligen Verfügung, im Media Code Action hieß das, gesperrt, ohne dass die in Wien das überhaupt erfahren haben. Weil der Witz eben der war, dass die Datenbank, die in diesem Fall diesen Word Action Punkt Com Eintrag, also die Datenbank, die das Punkt Com speicherte, eben in Minnesota stand. Und entsprechend eben könnte man sagen, amerikanisches Bundesrecht auf einmal auf Wien, Österreich, Europa angewandt wurde. Und das kann es natürlich auch nicht unbedingt sein. Also das ist so als Versuch sozusagen eine Antwort auf deine Frage, wie könnte das funktionieren? Das ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht ausprobiert wird.
Und dann wollte ich jetzt nochmal gegen die Zensur sagen, nämlich wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Satanistenmaterial zensieren würde, dann könnten die ja sagen, wir wollen jetzt, dass irgendeine andere Religion auch zensiert wird. Und so würde im Prinzip dann schlussendlich alles zensiert sein. Und ja, dann hat man gar keine Daten mehr.
Das wäre ein interessanter Vorstoß, wenn jeder zensieren darf. Dann könnte man im Grunde genommen das alles auch gleich abschalten. Na gut, und wie stürzt mir die Regierung?
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da war doch noch was.
Ich meine, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal an, okay, jeder darf jetzt zensieren. Da bleibt ja nicht mehr sehr viel übrig, aber na gut, vielleicht, hey, vielleicht ist das die Lösung. Was jetzt? Vielleicht wird die Regierung dann auch weg zensiert.
Erreichbar ist sie ja schon seit Jahren nicht mehr. Ich glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie was bringen würde, jetzt auch noch zu zensieren. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Na gut, da können wir nach den Nachrichten nochmal drüber diskutieren. Dann erfahren wir wahrscheinlich neuste Neuigkeiten unserer Regierung.
Aus Neuigkeiten aus der Müllverbrennungsanlage. Benny, herzlichen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Dann 89, 85.
Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen.
Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Ich hab noch ein paar Sachen. Heute Nacht minus zwei Grad. Am Tag dann wieder freundlicher und trocken um elf Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boerner. Bei einem palästinensischen Selbstmordanschlag auf ein Hotel in der israelischen Stadt Netanya sind mindestens 15 Menschen getötet worden. 80 Personen wurden zum Teil lebensgefährlich verletzt. Die palästinensische Delegation wird heute wieder am Arabischen Gipfel in Beirut teilnehmen, das sagte der palästinensische Minister für internationale Zusammenarbeit, Shaf. Zum Auftakt des Treffens hatten die Palästinenser gestern die Konferenz unter Protest verlassen, weil die Rede von Palästinenser Präsident Arafat aus Ramallah nicht live in den Litzsitzungssaal übertragen wurde. Drei Tage nach der Erdbebenkatastrophe in Afghanistan ist die Region am Abend von starken Nachbeben erschüttert worden. Angaben aus Kabul zufolge gab es dabei erneut Tote und Verletzte. Indessen ist die internationale Hilfe angelaufen. Die Personalräte sowie der Vorstand der angeschlagenen Berliner Bankgesellschaft haben sich auf eine vorläufige Sanierungsvereinbarung geeinigt. Danach sollen die Personalkosten um rund 300 Millionen Euro gesenkt werden. Innerhalb der kommenden drei Jahre müssen rund 4000 Mitarbeiter die Bank verlassen. Und zum Sport, die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft hat in einem Testländerspiel in Rostock mit 4 zu 2 gegen die 11 Groß-USA gewonnen.
Fritz präsentiert den Oster-Sonntag-Feiertag mit der 7-Jahr-Ost-U-Side-Club-Berlin-Party.
Mit dabei Tarnit, Wolle XTP, Tobi Neumann und Anja Schneider im Casino Münstraße 26-30 in Berlin-Friedrichshain. Mit Tiger, Woody und Klee im Polar-TV Heidestraße 73, Berlin-Tiergarten.
Ja, watch this. Was es noch zu tun gibt oder so ähnlich, nicht? Wir sind nur zwischendurch ein bisschen in dieses mehr oder minder zensierte Internet abgeglitten, was uns hier auf diesem tollen Bildschirm. Und da kamen wir uns gerade wieder auf den Bildschirm. Das ist ja am 23.05. unter den die Illuminatenflix unter den Hörern wissen. Das heißt, kommt ja Herr Busch nach Berlin.
Ja, aber du glaubst auch nicht, dass George W. Bush auch nur den Ansatz einer neuen Weltordnung, also ich meine, ich zitiere in solchen Fällen immer Philip Roth, diesen Schriftsteller, der gesagt hat auf die Frage, aber hat Bush das mit dem Krieg, also gegen Afghanistan, nicht prima hinbekommen, da hat Philip Roth darauf geantwortet, George W. Bush bekommt noch nicht einmal einen einfachen Aussagesatz richtig hin, geschweige denn einen Krieg. Also ich glaube, wir brauchen da keine Angst zu haben.
Ja, ich meine, dir ist aber bewusst, dass spätestens seit den späten 80er Jahren die Fernstellung von hohen Staatsrepräsentanten eine weit entwickelte Kunst ist, die wir in der Sowjetunion gesehen haben.
Das ist ja genau, dass es auf dem Illuminatus ausführlicher gewürdigt ist.
Außerdem ist Double ja der 23. Buchstabe des Alphabets.
Genau, außerdem kann man, wenn man George Bush und Verschwörung unsöhn, kann man nochmal irgendwie Sachen mit dem Skull and Bone oder und so weiter.
Nee, lass uns doch mal an dieser Stelle eine Werbung anrufen.
Lass uns mal das Thema reden.
Das Thema ist Zensur im Internet jetzt mehr oder weniger, nicht wahr? 0331 77 97 110, könnt ihr noch knappe 20 Minuten wählen, um mit uns darüber zu sprechen, wollen wir jetzt mit Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian. Kannst du mich ganz normal verstehen? Ich verstehe das nicht. Was ist denn das hier?
Olga, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich so, dass dein Mikrofon möglicherweise gar nicht, und die Hörer dich eher über unsere Mikrofone hier hören.
Ich hab doch mein Mikrofon eingeschaltet.
Du bist auf jeden Fall auf dem Kopfhörer in der Normal-Lautstärke zu hören, aber möglicherweise nicht auf dem Audiosignal, was zu dem Hörer geht, an seinem Telefon.
Bestimmt ist dann ein T abgestutzt und du weißt es nicht.
Dazu muss man wissen, dass Fritz hier ein funkelnagelneues, digitales Studio hat, das auf Windows-MT basiert. Man darf hier nicht mehr rauchen, weil dann kommt sofort die Feuerwehr. Wurden wir schon belehrt.
Vor allem kommt dann der Chef und haut dir auf die Finger.
Ich rauchte ja eh nicht.
Ich hab eigentlich nie wirklich geraucht.
Ach so, was macht das?
So, also das Thema. Was wollten wir jetzt gerade wegzensieren, sagtest du? Da war doch ein Hörer in der Latte. Entschuldigung, nein, die Frage war irgendwie falsch. Aber du hattest irgendwie...
Sebastian heißt er, damit du das nächste Mal den richtigen ansprichst.
Ja, nee, ich wollte nur sagen, es war irgendwie so gesagt worden, dass jetzt hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen so ein Projekt haben, das an Provider, also dass Provider bestimmte Internetseiten nicht mehr anzeigen können. Das ist eigentlich Schwachsinn. Denn in gewisser Weise würde es zwar helfen, weil dann so akut Leute, die sich solche Seiten angucken, dann erstmal vielleicht für ein, zwei Tage sich das nicht weiter an tun können. Aber dann geht man halt zu bestimmten Internetanbietern, also zum Beispiel BeepWorld oder so. Das ist so ein Provider, wo man sich kostenlos eine Homepage erstellen kann und da kostenlosen Server Space zur Verfügung gestellt bekommt. Und dann kann man halt sich da eine eigene Homepage erstellen.
Und da braucht man ja nicht extra nochmal anfangen.
Es gibt ja sogenannte Quelltexte. Das sind halt so die Texte, mit denen man so Internetseiten programmiert. Und diese Texte kann man sich dann einfach auf so einen Web-Server stellen und dann vielleicht noch unter so einer Subdomain registrieren. Es gibt so bestimmte Subdomains. Da kann man dann z.B..de, .tt, sowas gibt es alles. Und da kann man halt so die ganze Homepage neu einrichten lassen.
Und somit die Zensur umgehen dann. Aber irgendwie musst du ja auch die Information, dass du jetzt...
Ich bin ein bisschen lauter.
Ich kann nicht noch lauter sprechen. Ja gut, dann sag ich jetzt einfach gar nichts mehr. Sprecht ihr mit ihm?
Na halbwegs gehts noch, aber...
Ich sagte, irgendwie musst du ja auch die Information weitergeben, dass deine Seite unter einer anderen Adresse zu erreichen ist.
Naja, das ist halt das Problem mit dem Verlinken. Aber wenn man da auf irgendwelchen anderen Seiten, die nicht verboten sind, weil sie die noch nicht haben, wenn man das da angibt, dann die Seite und so, das ist eigentlich nicht das Problem.
Findest du also Zensur nur deshalb schlecht, weil es technisch nicht machbar ist?
Oder was ist auch ein generelles Problem damit? Es ist ja in bestimmten verbotenen Branchen mittlerweile gang und gäbe, was ich eben erzählt habe.
Was meintest du jetzt gerade mit verbotener Branche?
Ja, wo Urheberrechte verletzt werden beispielsweise.
Genau. Oder wo auf Datenschutz und so weiter, dann zum Beispiel illegale MP3s sind und noch viel mehr. Also alles diese Richtung. Das wird da gang und gäbe.
Illegales MP3s, weil Privatkopien sind erlaubt?
Da scheiden sicher die Geister nicht.
Man darf sie nicht im Internet zum Download anbieten, aber wird gemacht. Also es ist kein Problem, da ist jederzeit so eine...
Da wär ich mir nicht so sicher. Also die Rechtsauffassung ist da nicht eindeutig, ne?
An die...
Aufforderung zur Straftat?
Nein, nein, nein, Moment mal ganz kurz. Ich beziehe mich hier eher darauf, dass es gerade einen Entwurf des neuen Urheberrechtsgesetzes gibt, weil wir ja eine EU-Richtlinie haben, nach der das Urheberrechtsgesetz in ganz Europa vereinheitlich werden muss. Und ähm, den Entwurf, den ich hier habe, den Referentenentwurf, der sagt ganz klar, dass das Private kopieren, das nicht Gewerbliche. Also solange man dafür kein Geld nimmt und man das im Freundeskreis tut, ist das ganz klar legal.
Ist aber übers Netz zu vertreiben, ist Veröffentlichung...
Dass ich da jetzt auf Chaosradio in Sword fahre, aber da sind irgendwie nicht klar die Grenzen definiert.
Das ist richtig.
Es gibt so bestimmte Seiten, da kommt man halt rein, muss man auf bestimmten Toplists, also Fernsehtoplists erstellt, da ist halt so ein Netzwerk. Man stellt Werbung auf die Seiten und je höher die Klickraten sind, desto mehr Geld kriegt man für die Werbung und so weiter. Und da kann man halt jederzeit raufgehen und sich so ein MP3, wenn es dann funktionieren sollte, runterladen. Und das ist halt die Frage, also das ist kostenlos halt. Es geht halt nur, man sollte halt bitte voten, wird immer wieder gesagt. Und das ist halt die Frage, ob das Freundeskreis ist oder ob das illegal ist. Bei solchen Leuten wie Bertelsmann würde es überhaupt nicht gefallen, wenn ich die gleichen Sachen, die gleichen MP3s, die ich auf ihren Seiten bekomme, nur kostenlos vor anders kriege. Da ist eigentlich die Wahl nicht wirklich schwer.
Das ist zwar nicht Thema direkt der Sendung, aber ich gebe dir selbstverständlich recht, dass das, was du da gerade beschreibst, eher sozusagen auch zu Gewinnerzielung dient. Und sicherlich nicht das ist, was der Gesetzgeber da mit privaten Kopien meint.
Na, da das Thema der Sendung sowieso ständig wechselt, ist das eigentlich...
Ständig ist ja nun eine billige Propagandalüge.
Na, ist doch so. Erst gehen wir von, keine Ahnung... Zensur. Dann Zensur im Internet, dann wollen wir die Regierung stürzen, obwohl das wollte er sowieso.
Eine böseartige Unterstellung.
Irgendwie war das nichts weiter, als eine lustige Idee zwischendurch zu erhalten, wo die Holger gleich aufgreifen musste.
Das liegt darin, dass ich dich so ernst nehme, Komm mal Herr Direktor.
Das ist ja dein Problem. Das ist so, wie wenn du mit den Österreichern redest, da gibt es halt immer zwei Sprüche. Der eine ist, wenn ich dich auf verschicke, wo ich noch einen rüber und der andere ist, wir haben ihn ja nicht ernst genommen.
In diesem Sinne eine gute Nacht, Sebastian. Sebastian, kannst du mich hören?
Ja. Ich glaube, du musst einfach mal in dieses Mikrofon gehen.
Ja, aber das ist doch Quatsch. Ich meine, dieses Mikrofon ist extra hier hingebaut worden, damit ich da reinspreche und mich Menschen nicht nur an Radios, sondern auch an Telefonen verstehen.
Deine Kollegen mögen dich nicht, darauf musst du ja...
Wahrscheinlich hat sich da draußen irgendwie einer versteckt, zieht gerade irgendeinen Regler runter und denkt sich... Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Sebastian, ich wünsche dir eine gute Nacht. Und für den Fall, dass du das nicht richtig gehört hast, tschüss! Wir haben noch zwei Anrufer, die glaube ich verarzen wir noch und dann ist so ähnlich wie die Sendung wohl vorbei. Hallo Frank.
Hallo.
Er kann mich hören.
Ja, also bevor du den Anruf reingenommen hast, besser. Das ist also nur ganz leise im Hintergrund.
Das Leben ist hart.
Ja, also was ich sagen wollte, und zwar, also zum Glück nicht gut. Und ich möchte aber gleich auf das neue Thema einsteigen, und zwar, ich finde, das könnte nur umgehen, indem man Medienkompetenz schaffen würde in der Schule. Und das habt ihr ja schon mal gehabt in der Chaosradio-Berendung. Irgendeine 50er-Nummer war das. Und ich finde, das wäre auf jeden Fall auch der bessere Weg, als irgendwie versuchten Informationsverstecken zu betreiben oder so irgendwie was, wenn man halt wirklich den Leuten beibringt, wie man mit so einem Inhalt umgeht.
Ja, aber Medienkompetenz ist wesentlich teurer, als mal eben irgendwie eine Sperrverfügung zu erlassen, oder?
Deswegen reden wir von Regierungsstürzen. Nach dem Motto entweder bringen wir uns jetzt Medienkompetenz für die Bevölkerung, oder die stürzende Regierung.
Eine verdammt gute Idee.
Nee, nicht als stürzende Regierung, sondern als kreative Maßnahme. Ja klar, es ist wesentlich teurer, als einfach mal kurz so ein paar DNS-Einträge rauszunehmen. Aber wäre halt auch effektiver, auf lange Zeit gesehen. Weil, wie ihr schon bemerkt habt, so ein DNS-Eintrag kann man leicht umgehen. Und ich denke auch mal, ICANN wäre da nicht das Maßallermittel, wenn das wirklich dann so funktionieren würde, wie sich das alle vorstellen. Sondern dann würde es halt irgendjemand so einen eigenen kleinen DNS aufsetzen. Oder die Leute tausen halt wieder die Hosts.
Ja, ist ja schon geschehen, ja.
Obwohl ich ja eigentlich glaube, dass die Regierung da kein Interesse an medienkompetenten Bürgern hat.
Das ist ja dann praktisch 1984. Und wissen halt, ist Stärke oder ist ja irgendwie was. Aber ich denke mal, das ist so ein guter Weg. Also ich habe auch eigentlich vor, das bei uns in der Schule in Iling das einzuführen irgendwie.
Medienkompetenz?
Ja, mit den IT-Lehrern mal drüber zu quasseln. Aber das ist halt alles noch sehr träge.
Also ich denke, in dem konkreten Fall wäre eine gute Maßnahme zum Beispiel auch, sich sagen wir mal im Geschichtsunterricht verschiedene Darstellungen, geschichtliche Ereignisse von verschiedenen Seiten anzusehen und gegenüberzustellen. Also einfach mal ganz knallhart zu sagen, okay, wir gucken uns jetzt diese Nazi-Seite mal an. Was haben die denn zu sagen? Was sagen denn andere Quellen zu demselben Thema? Was ist vertrauenswürdiger? Was ist glaubwürdiger? Was davon kann man als das ist jetzt wirklich passiert betrachten? Ein großes Problem, das ich auch teilweise mit der Schule hatte, war, dass da immer die eine Weltsicht präsentiert wird. Die Welt ist so, wie wir euch das sagen, und nicht anders. Dass man erst wesentlich später darauf kommt, dass es eigentlich nicht die Wahrheit gibt, sondern dass es immer nur verschiedene Darstellungen der Wahrheit gibt. Und den Umgang damit zu lernen, das finde ich, ist eigentlich eine große Herausforderung in der Schule, die nach wie vor sehr unterschätzt wird.
Ja, es ist auch gerade so das Anspruchs. In der gymnasialen Oberstufe habe ich das mal angesprochen. Und zwar durften wir uns Themen wählen. Und dann habe ich halt mal vorgebracht, dass man sich vielleicht mal mit diesen sogenannten reformierten Historikern beschäftigen könnte, die ja alle sagen, ja, die ganzen KZs war ja nicht passiert. Das war ja bloß ein Hollywood-Film und so irgendwas. Weil ich das, was ich, hätte es als Stoff ganz interessant gefunden. Weil man ja auch wissen muss, was sich dann konfrontiert zieht. Vor allem, weil ich, also ich habe im engen Freundeskreis einen gehabt, der ist sozusagen zum Rechtsradikal übergelaufen. Mich hat das irgendwie interessiert, also ich meine, wie konnte der? Der ist nicht blöd und das muss einem doch auffallen. Und ich habe aber recht spät einen sogenannten reformierten Historikern erfahren. Also ich fand das halt schade, weil die Lehrlinge, die hat dann gleich abgeplockt, so ach ja, bloß nicht und ich kann bloß das Wort in den Mund nehmen. Und das fand ich halt dann einfach schade. Also Medienkompetenz, das fehlt halt.
Ich muss ja jetzt zugeben, ich habe mir diese Seiten tatsächlich auch mal angeschaut und mir das alles mal durchgelesen, was die Jungs da so schreiben. Und diese ganze Hypothese, es hätte die Vergasungen und Ausschwitzungen gegeben, die baut sich auf um ein Gutachten herum, das ein Chemiker mal angefertigt hat, der nach Ausschwitz gefahren ist und da von der ehemaligen Gaskammer ein Stückchen Wand abgekratzt hat und das analysiert hat und dann hinterher gesagt hat, ja, da hat es irgendwie diese oder jene Substanz nicht gegeben, die es hätte geben müssen bei der zu erwartenden Konzentration von Zyklon B usw. Aber da fand sich halt auch relativ schnell ein entsprechendes Gegengutachten, das gezeigt hat, dass die Ablagerung dieses Stoffes nicht linear ist mit der Gaskonzentration im Raum, sondern erst ab einer bestimmten Schwelle sprunghaft ansteigt. Und da hat man sozusagen zwei Gutachten nebeneinander liegen, die man nach wissenschaftlichen Kriterien beurteilen kann und kommt dann drauf, dass schon aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht, wenn man nur das betrachtet, das eigentlich Blödsinn ist. Und dann kommen halt noch Tausende von Protokollen, von Erlebnisberichten, von Menschen dazu, die im Zweifelsfall viel plausibler sind, weil ein wissenschaftliches Gutachten ist mit Sicherheit von der Wahrheit sehr, sehr viel weiter weg als Leute, die wirklich dabei waren. Also ich finde es auch in keinster Weise gefährlich, sich solche Seiten anzugucken, wenn man sich auch mal das anguckt, was andere Leute dazu zu sagen haben. Und die, die verblendet sind, sind eh verblendeter. Das ist hoffen und mal verloren.
Ich hab mir auch mal dann als ich später so eine Seite angeguckt von dem reformierten Historiker. Also ich war erstmal, war ich schon auch überrascht, weil was der so geschrieben hat, wenn man da nicht kritisch rangeht oder so was und sich nicht auch von der anderen Seite informiert. Also das war schon gut formuliert und alles überzeugend. Und gerade da fand ich dann eben, da hab ich mir dann gedacht, da muss man doch irgendwie von der Schule darauf vorbereitet werden. Auf solche Inhalte und das wegzuzensieren, das nützt halt nichts, weil irgendjemand hat's dann noch irgendwo.
Aber dann wird halt erst recht die Aura des Mystischen geschaffen. Oh, da muss ja was dran sein, wenn die das verbieten, das verbieten die ja nicht einfach so. Das ist dann natürlich das, was da im Kopf in dem Moment losgeht, bei vielen Leuten, was die eigentliche Gefahr ist. Auch da ist die Zensur in ganzer Weise hilfreich.
Ich finde es auch als ein extremes Schwachstelle von einer Demokratie, die sich einfach nicht mehr anders zu wehren weiß, als zu sagen, wir müssen jetzt zenzieren. Das fiel ich auch bei dem NPD-Verbot so, dass es einfach...
Es ist eben immer der billigste Weg.
Ja, aber es ist eigentlich den Teufel mit dem Bälzelbub ausgetrieben. Es ist doch schon gezeigt, die ganze Geschichte zeigt doch, dass Zensur nie der richtige Weg war. Da muss man nur die katholische Kirche angucken, oder das Nazi-Reich damals, oder was weiß ich was, es gibt ja genug Beispiele. Also ich finde es schwach, dass sozusagen die Regierung dann sich ein dummes Volk ranzüchtet. Also mir kam, als ich das gehört habe mit dem Regierungssturz, kam mir spontan die Idee, also es gab ja schon einen Militärputsch, es gab schon Bürgerkriege, vielleicht hat man mal einen Informationsputschplan.
Du meinst so Leute, also praktisch die Politiker, also die Regierung mit Informationen überladen?
Ne, andersrum. Andersrum? Wir nehmen diesen Proxy, den der Alvar da programmiert hat, setzen den einfach vor die Webseite der Bundesregierung und dann machen wir so kleine subtile Manipulation.
Die Rudolf Scharping dann garantiert merkt?
Ne, der ist ja nun eh durch. Innerhalb dieses Spielchen sozusagen. Ich meine eher so kleine Sätze, die dann die Leute schon nachhaltig so... Wobei, ich meine, die Frage, die man sich stellen muss, gibt es noch irgendeinen Kram, wo tatsächlich die Leute dann aufwerken würden, wo die sagen würden, ne, so eine Regierung will ich nicht haben. Da muss man dann nochmal über die Details nachdenken. Aber im Prinzip finde ich den Ansatz nicht verkehrt. Da muss man nochmal weiter...
Ja, was ich dir auch nochmal fragen wollte, und zwar, der Andi hat in der Sendung damals erwähnt, dass es da schon irgendwie ein Konzept gibt wegen Technik und Medienkompetenz. Und die Lisa war da in der Sendung und die hat irgendwie was erzählt von ihrer Schule. Und ob man da irgendwie noch an Informationen rankommen kann, wie das verlaufen ist, wenn ich dann mich darauf berufen kann, wenn ich das selber an der Schule durchführen will.
Ich meine, wenn du mal auf die chaosradio.ccc.de Seite gibst, dass es da irgendwo Links gibt, müsste ich jetzt aber selber rausholen. Sonst schick bitte nochmal eine Mail an, an was dann eigentlich? Keine Ahnung, Zeilezahl an mail.berlin.ccc.de Gut. Dann suchen wir dir das raus.
Frank, du hattest das letzte Wort. Die Sendung ist zu Ende. Ich danke für deinen Anruf.
Ja, kein Problem.
Könntest du mich denn gerade einigermaßen verstehen, wenigstens?
Ja, doch.
Das freut mich doch. Eine gute Nacht noch. Das war's Chaosradio 70. Vielen Dank für eure Anrufe. Vielen Dank, dass ihr vorbeigekommen seid, Jungs.
Wer mir wissen will, geht auf www.cccde.de Da gibt es noch eine lange Linkliste Unzensiert und so weiter und so fort.
Du bist mit der Stimme oben geblieben. Das ist für uns ein Bedeutete.
Frank will jetzt irgendwie noch auf seine Musikkiste drücken. Und du möchtest etwas.
Ich muss leider meinen Knopf drücken. Hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Herzlichen Dank Chaosradio 71 am letzten Mittwoch im April. Tschüss und gute Nacht.